Hello freaks,
we're live.
It took a while,
but we're here.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by carbonite.
Oh,
look at that.
I'm consistent.
Carbonite is a way to back up your files
online automatically without you even
have to thinking about half to thinking
about having to think about it.
More people working from laptops today,
giving them mobility and flexibility,
and in fact,
60% of workers use laptops as
their primary work computer,
but computer disasters can happen anytime
and anywhere affecting not only your
business files,
but possibly even every computer
that operates in your business.
That's why you need carbonite.
Online backup and laptops
can be expecially,
especially that's what George Bush says.
It especially vulnerable because 33%
of stolen laptops are taken from the
office.
28% from cars and about 12,000 laptops
are lost every week at US airports.
That's pretty ridiculous,
but if you have carbonite,
you'll have peace of mind
that you're backed up.
Files are always safe.
No matter what happens to your laptop.
Carbonite backs up your computer
files to the cloud automatically and
continually.
No matter how many computers your
business has or where they're located,
we rely on carbonate carbonate.
We were not,
were not very convincing,
but we mean it.
We rely on Carbonite to back up the
files here for the Joe Rogan experience
podcast.
It's super easy.
It's,
it's a,
it's great.
It's,
it's a peace of mind.
Go to karbonhq.com and
type in the offer code,
J r e for a free trial,
no credit card required plus two
bonus months with your subscription.
That's carbonite.com and the offer code
is j r e we'll also brought to you by
audible.com audible.com is the leading
audio provider on the Internet with over
150,000 titles.
It is a beautiful service.
I love it.
I'm a huge fan.
They have audio books,
they have podcasts,
they have comedy downloads,
they have the OPN Anthony show.
Is there any Graham Hancock
books on audible.com Yup.
Yes.
And tangled.
My first novel,
the first novel and uh,
the second one is war.
God is,
Oh God,
more God and war God.
Is that on a audible?
Yes.
It's not an audible yet,
but wait,
wait,
can I then get on at audible?
Jesus.
Louise's get cracking.
Um,
and in tangled is uh,
one of the fictional works
of Mr. Hancock and a,
we're going to talk about that.
We're going to talk about all
kinds of shit in a minute.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you will get a free audio book and
30 free days of audible service,
a service that I personally use.
I am a huge fan of audible and um,
they've been with supporting podcasts
and stand up comedy for a long time.
So I'm,
I'm a fan them,
uh,
just for,
for what they do and also
for their product itself.
It's outstanding.
It's just an amazing selection and I'm
just a huge fan of using audible books,
um,
and their service for
anytime I'm commuting,
anytime I'm on a plane,
it's just a,
it's a great thing to occupy your mind
and actually entertain you when you would
ordinarily be bored.
It's a fantastic service.
So it's audible.com forward slash Joe,
get your free audio book
and get hooked on audible.
I know you will love it.
We're also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com that's o,
n N.
I t if you haven't been
to on it for a while.
We have a lot of new products
including the Zombie Kettle Bells,
uh,
the primal bells,
which are all apes,
chimpanzee,
gorilla,
Orangutan,
and now a howler monkey,
which I guess isn't really an ape.
It's a monkey and an ape.
How's that work?
There's an April monkey.
I Dunno.
No,
no,
it's not right.
It's a tail,
right?
The tails.
The difference.
Right.
Cause I wouldn't have been quite
clear the ape shit a bit there to us.
Fair bit there to them.
One of the other one or the other.
But,
um,
these are all what they are is
functional workout equipment.
That is also awesome looking,
uh,
designed by Steven Shubin Junior,
who is an artist that on at higher
to create these bad ass designs.
Uh,
they're all three d balanced as well,
unlike,
um,
there's,
there's some other,
a kettle bells out there
that are a artistic,
but they're not balanced.
One of the more important parts of
creating these was that we wanted to make
sure that they were functional
for actually working out with,
uh,
so we,
we went above and beyond to make sure
that the d balanced and you can work out
with them just like a
regular kettle bells.
They just look more awesome.
We sell all sorts of other things
that ana including supplements,
hemp protein.
We sell blenders,
BLENDTEC blenders for making
protein shakes and Kale shakes.
We sell fitness equipment,
DVDs,
we sell books on nutrition,
Himalayan Sea salt,
you name it.
If it's good for your body,
we sell it at on it,
what we call on it is a total
human optimization website.
That's what the company strives to provide
you with all the things that you need
to optimize your mind,
your body,
your immune system,
your cognitive function,
so on and so forth.
And if you go to [inaudible] dot
com and use the code name Rogan,
that's o n n I t.com Code Ne Rogan will
save you 10% off any in all supplements.
All right.
Without any further ado,
the Great Graham Hancock is here and
I'm very excited to talk to you sir.
So cue the music
experience.
Joe Rogan podcast
are live,
ladies and gentlemen,
Graham Hancock gold whirlwind tour
across nations for many months.
And you're finally here in November,
2013 today's date is the
13th and you've been,
you've been it hearts in September.
I have been on the road since the second
day of September between and between
Dave had maybe like five days at home,
but the rest of the time
I've been traveling.
I've been,
let's see,
I've been in Turkey,
I've been all over Turkey,
amazing country.
My first ever visit to Turkey.
Did you got to do go back to,
I went to go back to the Tempe.
I spent more than a week at Gabelli Tempe.
I met Klaus Schmidt,
who's the actually rather decent
German archaeologist who is excavating
correctly.
Tempe.
I very rarely get on with archeologists,
but I got on with Klaus Schmidt.
I don't think he knew who I was but,
but somehow he was charming and he
gave us a lot of access to the site.
He led Santa get right in amongst
the pillars and then photograph them.
And we had a good time.
So over there and then took
the opportunity of being
in Turkey to travel over a
lot of the rest of the country.
There's some cool stuff that is like
what they call underground cities,
which go down eight,
10 stories under the,
under the earth.
The idea was that people build
them to hide from their enemies,
but in my opinion,
the last thing you'd want to do if you
were hiding from your enemies is wall
yourself up in some underground place
where all they have to do is just put a
stone across the door and you're done for,
I think they had some
other function than that.
So yeah,
we drove all over Turkey,
so a lot of amazing stuff.
Came back to England briefly then went
straight to Peru and Bolivia up in the,
up in the high Andes reached
a place in a hired car,
15,000 feet above sea level,
just over 15,000 feet.
That seriously high,
shorter breath up there.
And,
uh,
that was,
that was on the way to a site called
shoving one tar where they venerated
psychedelics in ancient times.
And uh,
also visited te Minako in
the Andes where in Bolivia,
where I've been a number of times before.
Fantastic place.
Uh,
came back from there,
went to South Africa,
spent five days in South Africa,
got on a plane immediately after returning
from South Africa and came to the
United States.
And I've been in the u s for the last two,
two and a half weeks.
Wow.
We got to get you some vitamin.
Sorry.
I need vitamins.
We really need to get you,
do you,
do you follow a healthy diet?
Well,
in a way I don't,
I don't eat meat.
I don't eat.
Maybe that's not healthy.
I don't,
I don't eat red meat.
I don't eat chicken.
I eat,
but I pick on shrimps and
scallops and things like that.
Otherwise I'm a vegetarian.
So fish and vegetables,
I don't eat fish.
No,
it has a backbone.
I don't eat things which I
don't eat things with backbones.
Only the when,
what,
what brought this about and I walk a trip.
No,
no,
I bought way back in 1986
when I was 36 years old,
I realized that I didn't
enjoy meat very much.
So I thought,
why did I become a vegetarian?
I became a vegetarian when not
for years and years and years.
Then I got bored.
I got seriously board with vegetarian
diet and I'd always liked shrimps and
scallops and shell fish of all kinds,
lobster,
stuff like that.
So I went back and started,
I lapsed and I started eating shellfish
and that's kind of where I drew the line
that I would,
I would eat as far away
from myself as possible.
Uh,
but I would definitely have
some flesh.
And so I,
I pick on these,
these creatures,
there's not particular
moral reason for it.
It's just a,
it's just what I like to do.
It seems a bit more,
although if you're trying to eat things
that are as far away from the post.
So I suppose so,
but wouldn't it be ironic if,
if I were to discover when I pass through
the veil to the next world that the
one thing that you're not
allowed to eat ever shrimps.
Imagine that.
I highly doubt there's
dietary requirements.
I highly doubt it too.
I had,
everything is temporary.
I mean we don't,
part of,
I think what's,
what's great about being a vegetarian or
being a Vegan is that you don't want to
take a life.
Yeah,
I appreciate that.
That's kind of what it
comes down to for me.
I appreciate that very much.
However,
lives are taking the manner what all
the time and you take life when you eat
vegetables,
you just take a different
type type of life.
Hey Life,
I'm wearing a leather belt right now.
I'm wearing leather shoes.
I took life to life,
eats life and it's not just animal life,
but plant life and fungal
life and all these,
I mean I see the point.
I just think it's a little short
sighted and utopian the view.
The view is just a little delusional.
But I appreciate the thought
and the sentiment behind me.
If I,
if I,
if I really enjoyed meat,
even chicken or red meat,
if I really enjoyed it,
I would eat it.
But I don't,
I never got,
I never got much out of it.
I never,
I was always a bit squeamish
about the blood and I never,
I never really wanted to eat it.
So I kind of felt it's a waste.
I don't,
I get no pleasure from this stuff,
so why?
So why should I eat it anyway?
That's why I say it's not
entirely a moral thing.
It's partly just a matter
of preference as well.
But I agree with you.
I mean everything in the web of
life on this planet lives off,
lives off everything else.
Uh,
I think,
I think maybe in our society,
in western technological society,
you know,
we've got so divorced from the act of
actually killing an animal that we forget
what we're doing.
We forget what's involved.
It's all very packaged and
sanitized and it's easy.
It's easy to forget what's involved in it,
that some,
some creature is,
is dying.
And in our culture of pretty unpleasant,
miserable death.
I agree.
And I think that that
separation is very immoral.
That separation between us and
our food to try to reconcile that.
I've recently taken up hunting,
I went hunting last year for the first
time and got a deer and killed it and
gutted it and quartered it and all
that jazz and eating it was incredibly
satisfying.
And also knowing that where I went,
these animals,
they're not going to make it,
no animal makes it,
but what the idea is,
you just breed as quickly as you can.
Your children live for a couple of years
and then they get taken out by mountain
lions or coyotes or the winter,
either freeze to death or what have you.
But it's a constant cycle.
And what I did is just
dip into that cycle.
And I think that's,
I have no problem with that.
And,
and you know,
it's,
it's much better actually go
hunt an animal rather than the,
the horrible cold industrial
slaughterhouses that we
have that we have now.
And the fear and humiliation the
animals are put through in that,
in that context,
at least,
at least in hunting,
it's,
it's kind of,
it's kind of one to one and,
and you are,
you are out there,
you're,
you're actually killing what you eat
and the animal lives in entirely wild,
natural life until the
moment you pull that trigger.
Yeah.
There's no,
there's,
there's no artificial
environment that it lives in.
There's no hormones and are
introduced into its body,
no antibiotics.
There's nothing unnatural about it at all.
Just the bullet hits it and that's
gone and it's over and it's virtually
painless because when a bullet
hits an animal like that,
I mean it's so fast and so quick,
they don't even know what happened.
They try to run and then they're done.
They're done.
You know,
and I think I would,
what I'm trying to do,
and I'm trying to do it this year,
by the end of this year,
I want to make my diet when I'm home,
when I can control it.
Completely wild game.
That's my goal.
While game,
which you will hook.
Yes.
Which I will hunt and for me and for my
whole family and I have this mapped out
this year,
I want to get deer,
I want to get a bison,
I want to get an elk and I would get
all these various animals and just do it
entirely to procure meat and to bring
it back home and deep freeze it and to
make sure that I always have wild,
natural meat available
if I want to eat it.
Well.
Before I went hunting,
I decided that I'm either going to
be a vegetarian after this trip.
I'm neither going to decide
that this is like really not me.
I don't really like it or
I'm going to become a hunter,
so I became a hunter.
Right.
I enjoy it.
I've always liked meat,
but I think it's also
because I participate so much
in like really strenuous
exercise,
Jujitsu and martial arts and yeah,
which requires,
requires you to have some
protein in your body.
There's no doubt about it.
Makes me crave it.
I don't know if I need it.
I know there's many people that work out
very hard that go on a completely plant
based Diet.
But for me,
I dunno,
whatever I think I need.
It varies from patient to patient.
But the hunting that you do or that you,
that you did to get this animal do,
I mean are you out there in nature?
Is it,
what's the scene?
How does it work?
I went to um,
well going next week actually,
but the first time I
went I went to Montana,
the badlands and Montana,
Montana actually where Lewis and
Clark went down the Missouri River.
It was fascinating because
it's incredibly wild.
I mean,
we saw we were there as a wild lab.
There's a lot of wildlife,
especially with Montana because
you can't grow out there.
So homesteaders tried to make these homes
out there and live and we took these
photos of him.
I should have brought some photos back,
but we took photos of these old homesteads
tights from the seven from the 18
hundreds and you know,
they're just rotted out.
Nobody could grow anything out of there.
And then the Indians,
the,
the natives wind up
killing a lot of people.
There was a lot of like between the Nez
Perce and all these people that lived
there and um,
the,
the time we were there,
we were there for about five days and
maybe we saw five or six other people the
entire time and they were just people
going down the river and canoes doing the
same thing,
hunting.
So you're having a wilderness experience,
there's a photo of it up there.
That's,
that's what it looked like.
It was completely wild.
No cell phone service,
no Internet,
no nothing.
Sleeping in a tent for five days.
Very,
very intense.
Very refreshing to like,
that was one of the things that I've
found fascinating about him going to bed
when it got dark.
Getting up in the morning
when it got light.
No cell phone service,
no,
no internet,
no.
Dealing with social media,
none of that nonsense that
we're constantly inundated
with on a daily basis.
Yeah,
I enjoyed it very much.
But um,
but you're not hunting an
animal that can hunt you back.
That's true.
But the animals that can
hunt you back are not really,
they're not really edible.
You can eat some of them I guess you
can eat grizzly bear like some people in
Montana or in Alaska eat grizzly.
I think they,
uh,
make grizzly jerky out of it and
some parts you can eat and outline.
You can eat the loin of a mountain lion,
apparently not really delicious.
It's not the best game.
Animals are essentially animals that are
all running from predators and you just
take part in that.
You just get,
you just get into the scramble.
You know,
in South Africa,
in the Kalahari desert of Namibia,
the Bushman there,
they would run animal style persistence,
hunting them down,
run them down.
They will run for like
12 hours just running,
running,
running until finally
the animal just says,
I'm done.
Yeah,
I've watched that.
I've watched that and videos online.
It's fascinating.
Amazing.
Native Americans used to do that as well.
Human beings are a rare animal
and that we can't outrun animals.
We can't like out speed them.
But we can keep going.
We can keep going for a long time.
And some animals just overheat.
They can't sweat,
you know,
and so they're,
they're designed for like these quick
sprints to get away from trouble.
But if we're just persistent
and we keep after them.
There's a podcast that I've
been listening to those was,
it was recommended by one of
the nurses at the Regina King,
Regina King,
however you say it,
the laboratory when I'm going to get
some blood work done called radio lab and
it dealt with this one particular tribe
in Kenya that has so many successful
runners right from this one particular
area and they were trying to figure out,
they did all these studies
to try to figure out what
made them so successful and
there was several factors.
One of them was their body shape.
One of them was the fact that they ran
to and from school on a regular basis.
They were constantly running.
But the other one was this
unbelievably brutal tribal ritual,
this coming of age ritual that the men
and the women went through the involve
genital mutilation with the men that and
involve the circumcision with a c sharp
stick.
And they would cover their face
with mud while they did this.
And if they crack the mud,
if they like squinted or Winston pain,
then they would be labeled a coward and
they would not have access to women.
They would like,
they would be cut out of the
economic situation in the tribe.
It's the most recent radio lab folks.
So if you,
uh,
I was recommended to me this,
this happens to these as a young man and
just entering puberty or who was at 13,
13,
and I think 17.
They said they,
they,
they circumcised them with a stick.
Not only that,
they keep this for skin on and they tied
in a bow and they push the head of the
penis through this bow.
And this whole ritual takes several
weeks in which time they're secluded.
And when they leave the hut,
they're like secluded in this hut.
When they leave the hut to do anything,
they are not allowed to walk.
They must run at full pace.
It also involves crawling
through stinging nettles naked.
They have to crawl through
the stinging nettle bushes.
The idea is just to completely control
your ability to withstand pain.
I got to be tough bastard.
Oh yeah.
So it's fascinating.
It's like this perfect storm of,
they have a,
an innate natural athletic ability based
on their frame and then it's also the
running on a regular basis and then also
the intense ability to withstand pain.
Absolutely fascinating.
Fast
thanks.
Dot well again,
I mean this is all stuff in a culture
that we've kind of completely got away
from set behind us.
We don't,
we don't even interrelate
with that at all anymore.
And,
and it makes you wonder,
I mean,
if the shit hits the fan
and our culture goes down,
who can survive?
Actually,
I think we're just going to go back
to if the shit does hit the fan.
And I know that's a
huge topic of your work.
And what,
what brought me to you in
the first place was uh,
your,
your work on the very clear evidence that
at certain points in history this shit
clearly did hit the fan and
people did have to rebuild.
I watch a lot of shows on subsistence
living in mostly in Alaska.
There's a lot of these shows.
Um,
life below zero is my new favorite one.
And it's all based on
these people living this.
One of them is this man who lives with
this woman and they just fish and hunt
and their family lives off of this
and it's absolutely fascinating.
The every day is spent
acquiring food and they're not,
they're hardly growing
anything because it's so cold,
right?
So everything is just about catching fish,
hunting animals,
preserving these animals in whatever
way would they're drying or you know,
and it's,
it's an amazingly brutal life,
but they seem to be very happy.
And this is one of the really confusing
aspects of this real traditional sort of
[inaudible] subsistence living that
people seem to feel satisfied by it.
That's kind of something
we were meant to do.
Maybe in a way,
I don't know if it's meant to,
but it seems like we evolve to do it well.
You have to consider that for,
you know,
anatomically modern humans stars we know
have been around for slightly less than
200,000 years and for
almost all of that period,
that's what we did.
That's what we did
where we're just really,
as you know,
at least if we go with mainstream
history and certainly it's true for the
majority of the human race,
whether we go with
mainstream history or not,
it's really only in the last 10
12,000 years that we've been,
that we've been doing anything else
apart from hunting and gathering.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a long,
long
time and we've tried to upset that
over the last 200 with machines
and electricity and all
these different things,
but we long for that created
a fundamentally a artificial
artificial way of life
and so quickly.
Yeah,
very rough.
It seems like our genetics have not
been able to catch up with the actual
environment,
but it was supported.
The,
the,
the irony of it is that this,
the oldest,
oldest development,
all this amazing technology,
all these machines,
all this gear,
all this equipment,
but somehow the promise was it would,
would make us happier and it didn't,
it didn't make us happier.
It made us,
it made us much less happy.
Yeah.
I don't know if that ever was the promise.
What was the problem?
I mean,
I,
you know,
I remember,
I remember with computers back in the
back in the 80s before computers really
early eighties late
seventies the idea was that,
you know,
if the computer came in that we would
just have all this endless Malaysia,
we would have a life
of complete relaxation.
There would be,
the problem would be
actually filling our leisure,
but that has not turned
out to be the case.
Everybody's lives are
taken up with the computer,
the,
the iPhone,
the email,
you know,
all that all the time.
You could never get away from it.
It's just constantly dividing your time.
Emails,
hundreds,
hundreds of emails a day.
Sometimes.
I,
I have this huge burden of guilt
about emails that I don't answer,
which sit there in my,
in my email is I cannot answer them all.
It's impossible.
I gave up a few years ago
trying to answer them.
I try to respond to a few
tweets a day if possible,
but yeah,
while doing things,
especially providing as much content as
I do with podcasts and creating comedy,
all that,
there's no time for that.
You can't become a
fulltime letter right here.
Yeah,
it would.
That literally would be what you would do.
It would be any,
you would be dusk till dawn
doing that and then sleeping.
It's starting all over again and
you still would never catch up.
You'd never catch.
Especially if you gave
it a real honest reply,
like it was a complex discussion that
somebody one and a half with you,
you're not going to get there.
Yeah.
I faced the same problem
probably in a smaller,
a smaller level than you,
but you know like Facebook and Twitter,
Facebook,
Facebook I find is very,
it's a very useful thing.
It's a very,
very positive thing.
I do like interacting with
my Facebook community,
but I can't interact.
I can't interact that much.
I tried to,
I tried to put up posts,
I tried to put up new material.
People make interesting comments.
Sometimes those comments
are really valuable to me.
I get a link to something that
I didn't know about and I go,
go look at that.
But to respond to every
comment when you have,
when you have 300,
500,
a thousand,
1500 comments on a,
on a post,
it's impossible.
It's just,
it's just impossible to do that.
That is a weird thing about our time.
I think that's a stage
that we're going through.
There'll be,
I think whatever comes next will
probably be even crazier and even more
impossible to deal with
it halfway to telepathy.
Right.
And then,
yes,
that's what I think.
I think,
uh,
there'll be some sort of a technologically
created symbiotic relationship that
allows us to communicate some
symbiotic thing where I'm thinking,
I think we're already kind of symbiotic
with certain aspects of technology,
glasses and even glasses
are essentially a technology that's a
part of your life and wearing on your head
all day,
right?
Yeah.
I do.
Cell phone might mean it might as well
be attached to me because I'm scared.
If I leave it anywhere.
If I leave it in my car
and I go to the mall,
I'm like,
oh,
it's in the car.
I was alone.
Yeah.
We were.
These are weird times,
weird times when it comes
to this stage that we're in.
We're obviously progressing towards
an even greater connectivity with our
technology.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Which in some ways is a,
in some ways it is a
very good thing I have,
what I find again with,
with Facebook,
with the,
with the Internet is a,
suddenly the whole world is talking.
We're talking to each other and it
doesn't actually matter what national
boundaries you have or where you,
where you grew up,
what your religion is you're in,
you're in communication with people from,
from all over the world and communities
of ideas tend to kind of gravitate
together and people share,
share thoughts and ideas.
This is far as we know is
a new development for the
human race to do this on a
global scale and yeah,
some shit comes out of it,
but also also I think a lot of good
stuff is coming out of it and it is
challenging.
It is challenging the status
quo in the world today.
It is very,
it's very threatening to the powers that
be that people can communicate directly
with one another.
I remember a time as an author when I
depended heavily on the big media to to be
heard about,
to be known at all.
If I'd written a new book,
How could anybody know I'd written it
unless one of the big newspapers are a big
TV station or somebody covered it.
I don't give a shit about that now.
I don't.
I don't need those people anymore.
You know,
I,
I can communicate directly with
people who are interested in my,
and the big media companies or whoever
influenced them could remove a book towed
from the market and then that,
that subject is gone.
Yeah.
John Marco Legros book,
perfect examples of sacred
mushroom and the cross.
Fantastic book.
Yeah.
And if you've never read it,
John Marco leg was a biblical scholar
and a linguist to also happen to be an
ordained minister.
He was one of the guys who was,
he was,
uh,
assigned to decipher the Dead Sea Scrolls,
did it for 14 years and
wrote this amazing book,
which basically said that the entire
religion of Christianity originally was
about consuming psychedelic
mushrooms and fertility rituals.
Yeah.
Fascinating stuff.
They removed it.
I mean,
that book was gone.
They didn't like the message at all.
Yeah.
Young urban has,
has worked to republish it and it's,
it's available again now.
But for the longest
time that book was gone.
You had to find,
I own two copies of it that I bought
used and they were very expensive.
You had to buy them from,
you know,
some strange book company that found them.
So this is something in the big,
big media,
can't do anything.
We'll do it.
And the interest they serve,
they cannot do it anymore.
You could find something tweeted,
so take a picture of it.
Say if you were in Turkey and
you found something unique,
you can take a picture of that,
tweet it and,
and,
and Lincoln article to your website.
Boom.
Put whatever you found on your website.
And then within moments,
yeah,
thousands of people would be downloading
it and trading it and it would just
frenzy spread across the world.
I've been doing that.
I'd be making a point on my travels of,
of putting up a picture and I'm putting
up my immediate reaction to something
that I've,
something that I've seen.
And it produces a lot of,
a lot of reaction.
And,
and again,
it's a,
you know,
it goes,
it goes two ways because when
people communicate with me,
I learned from them.
It's not just that I'm giving,
I'm giving people,
so I'm getting stuff back all the
time and I appreciate that my,
I think my,
I have these conversations with people
that I meet at shows all the time,
will they'll say,
oh,
this pot,
the podcasts changed my
life and thank you so much.
It changed my life too and my interaction
with these people as changed my life
as much as it's changed their life.
The,
the,
the information that I get on a daily
basis from people on Twitter in informs me
in a way that I've never
been informed before.
Constant all day long.
I mean every day I'm getting all these
new stories that are tweeted to me and I
retweet the fascinating
ones as much as I can,
but it's a never ending stream.
It's amazing.
I love it.
I'm so,
I'm so indebted.
I'm so happy.
I feel so obligated.
The whole,
the whole connection is a very
rewarding connection for me as well.
As a matter of fact,
you are doing something quite special.
I mean,
I've been on the road and,
and it's amazing the people that I meet,
whether it's in South Africa,
whether it's in some
Midland city in Britain,
whether it's in upstate New York,
you know,
who'd listen to Joe Rogan.
Um,
you're reaching a lot of,
a lot of people that way.
And uh,
this is special and it's eyeopening.
Well,
it's an amazing connection that we have.
It's in a,
it's amazing to be able to do what
we're doing and it's a new thing.
I mean,
it's,
it just,
it never happened before.
It wasn't around this way.
It's possible to change the world.
Everybody says no,
the world is too big.
The power structures to great,
nothing can be,
nothing can be changed.
Nothing.
But it can be able to,
but I don't think so.
I'm really optimistic,
I think.
I think good things are good.
Things are coming.
There's an awakening going on.
I am as well.
I'm very optimistic just based on the
people that I've met that have told me
they've changed their life.
I have met no,
no bullshit.
At least 30 or 40 people that told
me they lost a hundred pounds if they
listened to this podcast.
That's incredible.
Just people that just change their diet,
started to exercising and started
getting their blood pumping and feeling
better.
It started thinking positively
cause surrounding themselves
with positive people
and that if that could
be done on that scale,
that can spread virally.
That's totally can.
And that's a real measurable
change in somebody's life.
That's,
that's setting aside ill
health and discomfort and
moving onto something better
and more positive.
And I've talked to maybe 50 or so people
that have started their own podcast
because of this podcast and I,
I'm hugely encouraging of that
because I think there's no difference.
I mean,
if you're a curious person,
you speak a language that other people
understand and you find information
online,
you want to discuss it,
start a fucking podcast.
Why not?
I mean,
if,
if it catches on,
it catches on and if it doesn't catch on,
keep
going until it does catch on.
The way I see it though,
it's really,
it's really interesting looking at,
at your story.
Okay.
I mean,
so you've got this fight,
this fight,
her background,
MMA,
I don't know a lot about if it
stands for mixed martial arts,
UFC ultimate fighting championship
to bit fighting championship.
And that goes back into
your youth a long way.
I saw it,
I saw a little clip of
you just kicking somebody.
I dunno so fast.
You didn't,
you looked,
it was a,
it was incredible to see that.
So you've got all of that and,
and I meet a lot of people who are,
who are interested in that.
My son in law,
for example,
is a,
is a mixed martial arts
fighter and they really,
hugely important part of his life.
But at the same time you're combining
it with this extraordinary interest in
psychedelics and social change and,
and all of these radical ideas.
And intuitively one would not immediately
think that somebody who's into mixed,
mixed martial arts fighting would be
also into radical philosophical ideas.
But it's the precisely the combination
of those two things that is a,
that is really attractive I think.
Well,
I think that the intuition or intuitively
that it wouldn't be is just because
people don't understand what
martial arts really are.
Right?
In martial art with a
martial art really is,
is the,
the the path that you go through in
becoming excellent in a martial art,
it's just developing your human potential.
That's all it is and and seeking the
truth about yourself and your own
character.
Like as we were talking about those Kenyan
men who endure extreme pain and they
become stronger because of that,
they become something
special because of that,
that seeking truth
through martial arts is,
it's along the same lines.
It's doing something incredibly difficult
and in doing that you grow as a person
and then in seeking that
truth about your character,
seeking the truth about
your determination,
your willpower,
your focus,
your discipline,
you also start to seek truth in everything
else around you and your government
and your relationships and your all,
all various aspects of your life,
your diet.
You see the relationship between your
diet and your health and all these
different things they do fall into.
They do psychedelics,
all of them.
Psychedelics.
Absolutely because it because in in
many ways there is no more challenging
adventure or experience that one can have.
I mean,
yeah,
there's all kinds of wilderness
experiences weren't going to have,
but a deep journey with a powerful
psychedelic is going to challenge you in
every possible level as a human being
and it requires incredible will and
strength to,
to deal with it.
This is what a lot of people who don't
work with psychedelics who had just
washed brainwashed by the whole war
on drugs thing don't understand.
This is a,
this is a deep personal journey which
requires strength of character to fulfill.
Without a doubt.
I've done some terrifying
things in my life,
but the moment before you,
you light the lighter that fires up
the DMT is one of the most terrifying
moments of all time.
I totally agree.
Especially if you've been there and
you know what's coming and you're like,
Whoa,
here we go.
15 minutes in a rocket to
the center of the universe,
exact swarming with colors and
geometric patterns and truth and fear
and entities.
Yeah,
I,
I share that.
I mean,
the last time I,
the last time I smoked DMT was in up to
the beginning of the end of September,
2011 I haven't smoked since because,
and I will.
But I had,
I had such a,
such a,
well at the word terrifying.
It doesn't do it justice
to what happened to me.
It was,
it was just the,
the single hugest ordeal that I
have ever confronted in my life.
And after you've been
through an ordeal like that,
you kind of,
you kind of think twice
about just leaping,
leaping back into it again.
But I learned a lot from it.
It was,
it was a hugely,
hugely beneficial and to survive
that and to come back from it,
you know,
you,
you gather your strength
from experiences like that.
And that's why I,
that's why I think our society is foolish
to try to just sanitize everything and
not allow people to,
to,
to undergo these,
these profound and important experiences.
We'd rather we should be
creating structures where
it is possible for people to
have those experiences and where they
don't need to feel afraid of the law about
it and where they,
where they can challenge themselves in
that way with good advice and with and
with wise and loving care
surrounding that situation.
Absolutely.
And I think that's one of
the things that's beautiful
about today's internet and
these exchanges like we're having right
now is it lets people know what these
experiences really are about and what,
what the potential these
experiences actually do hold.
Because we're the victim of massive
propaganda that has been going on for
decades and decades and
it's thousands of years.
It's confused.
Some really intelligent people.
I've had some really disappointing
conversations with guys like Michio Kaku,
you know,
talking about mushrooms,
giving you brain damage,
such shit.
It's just so silly complete.
It's such a brilliant man.
Otherwise it's like the brainwashing
goes very deep and it's as though it,
it presses a button in certain certain
people that they actually just rational
faculties shutdown and they cannot,
they cannot react to the subject
in an intelligent way anymore.
I do.
I do find this again and again.
It is a,
it is a,
it is a huge problem.
It's a self preservation issue as well
for people that are professionals.
Because if you're a
professional in any sort of,
uh,
anything where you're being judged or
you're being looked at as you know,
possibly,
oh,
you know,
we're looking at you
for possible promotion,
but we heard your,
what are you doing?
Mushrooms and the desert.
What the Fuck Bob,
you're ruining the whole career pal.
You know,
you're on the fast track.
Yeah,
exactly.
People,
people are,
are,
are in danger of destroying
their careers if that,
if that comes out.
I mean that's where I
guess you and I have some,
some advantage because we,
we have careers that cannot get
really in doing that can only help.
Yeah.
If I get caught with a bag
of mushrooms at the airport,
I got a bump.
Everything is great.
Right,
right.
We get excited.
My Twitter explodes.
Yeah.
I mean,
obviously I'm not flying with mushrooms,
but my point being that,
yeah,
and if you're honest about it,
look,
if you're doing something you shouldn't
be doing because it's harming someone
and people find out about it,
the repercussions are
real and they should be.
Yeah,
but if you're doing something like
psychedelics that harm no one and they're
actually,
and then you can have a
rational discussion about
the benefits that you've had
from them that helps people.
It really does.
Totally helps people.
I find this,
I find this again and again and
that's the crucial distinction is,
is are you doing something
which is harmful to others,
which impinges upon the
sovereignty of others,
which makes the life of another
person less rather than more.
And the answer is we'd
taking psychedelics.
No,
you're not right.
You're not doing that.
That's an inner experience
that that's your,
that's your own experience.
As I've said many times,
I mean we all,
we have plenty of laws that deal with
doing negative stuff too to other people.
We do not need laws that seek to govern,
control,
manage,
limit our consciousness.
This is the,
this is the heart of the matter we're
starting to see in our lifetime these
centers in Mexico.
My friend Ed clay runs one in Mexico and
I know there's some in Canada as well,
where they have these Ibogaine centers
where people are going and completely
curing themselves from opiates.
Opiate addictions for folks who don't
know are a huge problem in this country.
I have lost a couple of friendships.
One,
it went horribly wrong because I know
the guy was on a bunch of different pills
from a bunch of different doctors and
I just couldn't deal with them anymore.
I had to get up out of my life blaming
other people for all of its failures
constantly.
Woe is me and just on pills all the
time and things have prescribed pills.
These are illegal pills.
He had a back injury and he went to one
doctor in one state and then moved to
California and started
going to another doctor.
And then having both guys
sending prescriptions and
taking both two times the
amount of pills.
And if you would take,
you take a prescribed
dose of opiate pills,
you're very likely to get addictive.
Yeah.
Even with the prescribed dosage,
she'll really difficult
time to get off of them,
especially if you're facing
some significant pain.
Yeah.
You just had a hip replacement.
Did they prescribe you any?
Yeah,
they did.
Um,
I was given but nothing,
I mean,
nothing extremely strong,
but codene you know,
which is,
which is an opiate,
like,
well that's what Nyquil used to have it,
right?
It does.
It I used to.
I believe so.
I believe Nyquil had coding.
I mean,
coding is actually a
highly addictive drug.
It's a,
there's no,
there's no doubt it is,
it is addictive.
In Britain.
David often mix it with paracetamol,
which is a,
which is a less strong pain killer.
And,
uh,
if you take those,
those two pills in combination,
you could get addicted to
it within a week or 10 days.
Um,
and it's the coding that
you're getting addicted to,
but it's the paracetamol that's really
good to totally screw up your liver,
you know,
um,
in the,
in the long run.
And,
and it's,
it's stunning actually that the,
the big pharmaceutical companies
are allowed to do this.
They're allowed to get to deliberately
addict people to Hook people on very
powerful drugs that I
really have very little,
very little benefit.
I mean,
if I,
to be honest,
if I had some,
some terrible cancer,
some terrible pain,
some terrible suffering,
I would be very interested
in exploring opium or,
or even heroin.
As a matter of fact,
I think that nature,
nature has been kind to us.
It's provided us with certain plants
that can help us with pain and,
and the reaches a stage,
it may reach a stage in life where,
where you're,
where your,
where your terminal,
where,
why suffer that,
why suffered that terrible agony.
Um,
it would be,
it would be interesting perhaps to,
to,
to sort of bliss out a bit on that,
but to take it regularly,
daily for Small and minor pain,
this is a huge mistake.
It's not what it's for.
There's a new,
a snail toxin that they've discovered
that is a hundred times more effective
than opiates and his non addictive.
Oh Wow.
And they're trying to figure out a way.
There's a,
there's a new drug is from the cone
snail venom and it's a hundred times more
potent than any existing pain
medication and completely nonaddictive.
And they're,
they're coming up with this nail venom
in a pill form that would just completely
eliminate pain.
I can see the,
um,
the big drug companies
not wanting to do that.
They'll probably run out with a hammer
and smash every snail that exists.
Lash
get in cahoots with some,
some company to spray some shit all over
the areas where these nails live and
just whack them out.
All they wanted to keep us,
they want to keep us addicted.
Well,
the amount of money,
I mean,
people would say that
that's a ridiculous thing.
No,
that's not what people do.
But the amount of money you're talking
about is absolutely staggering.
Cost an enormous billions
upon billions every month.
Yeah.
And you were talking about about opiate
addictions of which the vast majority
are addictions to prescribed pills and,
but,
but then there's also,
there's also heroin,
heroin addiction.
And again,
if again,
um,
and in fact Iowasca astonishingly
successful in getting people off these off
these addictions,
a very weird way,
very weird way.
Um,
I,
I'm,
I'm not sure the exact mechanism Ibogaine,
but I,
the people that have taken it if told
me that it's both physically removed,
the addiction and more
importantly psychologically
alerts you to all the factors
that have contributed to your shitty
decision making in the first place.
That's it.
Exactly.
All the Evers in your thinking,
all the errors in your personality that
have led you to this path and you're
just trying to numb life with these pills.
It's like a,
it's like a teaching that you get and
that's the mystery of these plants
actually have th th the teacher plants,
particularly the two plants that go into
the Iowasca brew and then they Boca,
uh,
they're probably the
most powerful in this,
in this respect,
is that there is that there's a sense
of an encounter with an intelligence
which,
which communicates with you at which
gets right to the root of your personal
issue.
Uh,
and,
and shows it to you and says,
well,
I mean,
I've had some experience with this
myself and shows to you and says,
this
is actually how you are,
you know,
and you think,
fuck,
I never realized that.
Really.
I,
I hid that from myself for so long.
The Ego,
the ego and that revelation
is extremely helpful in,
in handling an addiction and no ones
protecting you by making Ibogaine,
illegal,
no ones protecting you from anything
other than you getting cured from these
illnesses and,
and realizing the issues that you have
in your life and in your personality.
And you can see yet another example of
the fact that we live in a society that
is completely insane.
Our society at is actually crazy.
It's crazy.
It's run by crazy people in pursuit
of crazy motives and it is designed to
diminish you and potential.
I can't help,
I don't think it's accident.
I think it's actually deliberately
designed to minimize you by who?
Well,
I mean this is where I have to get
into something like Gnosticism,
which has been a long term,
a long term interest of mine.
And the idea that there is a,
I don't want to use the word divine
in terms of God cause I don't go with,
with,
with God particularly
I do go with mystery,
but that there's a divine spark in,
in human beings and,
and that there has been a project
for thousands of years to deny us the
opportunity to realize
that part of ourselves,
the spiritual essence of ourselves and
to keep us chained in matter and locked
in,
locked in the material realm.
And,
and what we see in modern society
is two things going on side by side.
One is so called the materialist science,
which tells us that there is nothing
else to reality except the stuff that you
can weigh and measure and count and
any thought that there might be spirit,
uh,
that consciousness,
for example,
might not be a generated by the brain,
might not be local to the brain.
Any such thought is supposed to be
according to materialist science,
complete nonsense.
And then there's the
actual materialism which,
which tries to persuade us through all
manner of media and the way our society
is run,
that our sole purpose as creatures is to
produce and consume and that we have no
other function here on this planet and
that we are to define ourselves and
measure ourselves in terms of
our production and consumption.
Is that a really what we're being taught
or is that just something that people
find easy,
that that producing and
consuming is just easy.
It's exciting.
Get a new car.
Get a new TV that's exciting work and you,
you know,
you can wear clothes
that this guy can't wear.
Ooh,
exciting.
I think there's something to that that
is just a natural aspect of being a human
being and constantly having this
desire for improvement and progress.
And we measure that improvement and
progress erroneously with objects.
I mean,
there was a,
there was a culture of,
uh,
of native American Indians,
I forget the,
I forget the name of the tribe who had
this ceremony called the potlatch where
the PR,
which happened like once a year and
their project that what they had to do as
the,
the more things you could burn that
showed,
that showed that you
were a really big guy.
You know,
he just,
just complete the ultimate conspicuous
consumption as you take all these
possessions and burn them.
Not because you're despising them,
but because you're rich
enough to just barely,
oh,
that's so stupid.
I thought it was to
free yourself from this.
Now unfortunately not,
unfortunately not.
Yeah.
The,
the consciousness not being,
uh,
projected from the human mind is a very
confusing one to me because I see their
point and I see your point.
I see,
I see.
What I see is I don't think that
we know enough about consciousness.
It's excel itself to
define what's going on.
We can't be sure.
I think it is possible that the
mind could be some form of antenna.
I don't know that,
I think it's pretty clear that if
you injure certain parts of the mind,
it affects certain aspects
of cognitive function.
I think that's pretty clear.
It's pretty clear.
Yeah,
that's true.
And an antenna to the damage,
if you damage an antenna,
the picture on the TV screen is affected.
Exactly.
Fuck up a radio,
the insides of a radio.
It doesn't mean that the,
the signal's not still out there.
Yeah.
It's just not getting in.
Right.
Yeah.
There's that.
And there's also,
there was a fascinating debate recently
between a Richard Dawkins and Deepak
Chopra,
which,
uh,
it was,
it was quite hilarious cause Richard
Dawkins is a very brilliant guy.
He,
he's,
he's also kind of cunty.
He gets a little conti,
rightly so.
I mean,
he's,
he's had to deal with so much
quackery and fuckery his whole life.
And he's been,
you know,
uh,
of rabid atheists atheist for the longest.
He's made a career out of that,
has made a big career out of that.
But one of the things that Deepak said
that was really fascinating because they
were talking about consciousness
and consciousness being an Adams and
consciousness being in,
and Dawkins was insisting that these
things did not have consciousness,
which to me is,
oh,
I go,
I,
how can you insist?
It seems to me.
Yeah,
it seems to me that,
but whether you clearly you're,
he's a brilliant man with a massive
amount of scientific data at his disposal
for things that he can prove for sure.
But to say that you know,
that Adam's don't have consciousness
is kind of silly because we don't,
and the other thing that Deepak said
that I thought was really fascinating was
that he believes that what w what
you're seeing in human beings with human
beings being recycled star dust me,
we literally are made of star dust.
A star had to explode to create the very
molecules that are inside of our body
and what you're seeing in the human
being is the universe actually becoming
aware of itself in a way
that it can communicate.
I think that's a beautiful idea.
It's a beautiful idea and I think both
guys are so rigid on what their side is,
you know,
and especially in the,
in a debate forum and Dawkins absolutely,
sure he's correct.
Depok confusing the fuck out of everybody
with word salad of quantum and this
and that.
He just throws quantum out there.
Like you throw salt on French fries,
right?
I don't even know if it's
the right way to use it,
but he just throws it out there
and confuses the shit out of you.
Sometimes like very poor method of
communication he incorporates because it's
not clear what he's saying.
Even though I know what quantum means.
I know,
I know what he's talking about when
he's talking about consciousness being
nonlocal.
I understand all those things,
but he says it in such a word
salad way that it's like,
what?
Oh,
I don't know what you're getting at.
Man seems to me like you're trying to
confuse the shit out of people with a real
elaborate sentence.
Could be,
and then when this
debate or make it clear,
make a point.
That's our goal to win
bait.
Would Richard Dawkins,
Richard Dawkins is a very clever guy.
I,
I've,
I've met him and he's um,
he's a formidable uh,
arguing.
Yes.
It's not easy.
Not Easy at all,
but he is a religious
fanatic in his own way.
His,
his,
his non belief in the meaning or purpose
in the universe is a religious idea of
a kind.
It's not based on facts.
It's not based on evidence.
It's based on his,
his opinion.
As a matter of fact,
nothing more.
Well,
it's also based on a lack of information.
And when I say that lack of information,
I mean one thing and one thing
only psychedelic experiences.
He has not had them.
He needs to have them without a doubt.
You need to have the million.
I would like to,
I would like Dawkins to smoke DMT.
Yes.
That's the one.
That's the one psychedelic with
which there is just no negotiation.
You don't,
you just don't get a discussion with DMT.
It just does for you.
And,
and the other ones that
even the DMT in Iowa,
Asca Dawkins could resist that,
but the smoke DMT,
once you hit the right dose,
once you pass that fourth,
fourth big draw on the pipe there,
then there is no negotiation.
It is going to take you there
and it's going to deal with you.
And,
and I would like to see
Dawkins argue with DMT.
You can't,
um,
he would probably argue with what the
effects are and that it's some sort of a,
uh,
an assault on the sort of visual Cortex
by various chemicals that distort
perception and reality.
That's what he'd do.
Yeah.
I mean,
what it is though is data and what it is,
is an experience and it's both things
he's lacking in and he's lacking in that
data.
And the,
that experience data that he
needs to have as a scientist is,
he's one of the,
one of the people I would
really like to see having that,
having that data.
I agree with you that he would probably
find a way to rationalize it and put it
and set it aside,
but still it would be incredibly useful
for him to have that experience because
he's been so influential in persuading
so many people that there is nothing
beyond this material realm and DMT is
a place beyond this material realm.
I am prepared to admit it could be
something that we're projecting out of our
own minds.
It may not be any relative to,
but it feels like a real place.
I appreciate you,
uh,
admitting that,
and I say that often as well.
I think that it feels like a different
dimension that's inhabited with
intelligent thought,
something,
whatever is intelligent.
Something I,
I,
the way I described as geometric
patterns that are made out of love and
understanding what it feels like to me,
I have never had a bad DMT trip
in a sense where it turned evil,
but I've heard people discuss like really
horrific evil entities if they've run
into,
and I often wonder by virtue of that,
whether or not what they're talking about
is something that's in their psyche.
Something that's in their subconscious,
something that I bring it to the party.
Yes.
My,
my last DMT trip,
which I mentioned a little while ago,
which was,
which was extremely powerful and scary.
Um,
this was the time,
this,
this happened just a into two weeks
before I gave up my 24 year kind of what's
happened.
Um,
and I think I had some shit to go
through and I think the DMT was partner.
I then followed that with
five I wasco sessions.
But I think the DMT was really helpful.
And I may have mentioned this
to you the last time we talked,
but what,
but what happened as I,
as I went under,
I had that fourth deep
inhalation of the pipe lay,
lay back and,
and I don't normally hear voices and Dmt,
but a voice spoke to me
and the voice said to me,
your hours now,
Whoa,
your hours now.
And my last conscious thought was,
shit,
yes,
but only for only for 12 minutes,
you know,
and then,
and then I,
I've felt myself being ripped apart.
There were these things,
the small things.
I was looking on some kind of table and
they were running around me and they
were tearing me apart.
My body was torn to pieces,
bits where cast of was like a
cocoon was being ripped away and,
and,
and then the voice comes again.
There's like a trumpet call and the
voice comes again and now the great
transformation shall begin.
And it was,
it was the weirdest and
strangest experience.
And I was in this flickering huge space
and these little beings we're running
around me and they were doing it and
I was completely helpless and at their
mercy and that,
that was scary.
That's amazing.
But it was not demonic.
It was like,
it was like,
this is stuff you need to go through.
You need to,
you need to do this.
It's going to be very,
very frightening,
but it's something you need to do.
And I did need to do it
and it was helpful to me.
Was that the first time
you'd heard voices?
Yeah,
I never,
I did.
I did not hear voices speaking
to me and DMT ever before.
Wow.
I,
my,
my experiences had been filled with voice.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well,
one of the big ones is,
it's a really childish
thing that they would say,
and this was like when
I was about to leave,
when I was starting to sober up,
they would say,
I love you 600 million,
500,000 times.
Like a child would say,
oh,
I want to hit that.
I want to hit that more than
I wanted to hear your hours.
Well,
I think I came into it in a good place.
I was in a happy place in
my life and I wasn't scared.
I wasn't fighting it.
Yeah.
But that I love you
thing was really weird.
The other thing that it said
was the words of Mckenna.
And I think when I've
tried to analyze this,
I think that what it was was that I had
listened to so much mckenna before I'd
gone into it,
that I had sort of stained my
brain with this idea and either my
subconsciousness was saying this
or they were whatever they are,
whether they're,
you know,
a part of my,
my thought process,
we're projecting this thing,
this reminder,
do not give into astonishment.
And that that was because
it was so mind blowing.
I was flying down this
bumblebee covered like pathway,
this spinning,
when I say bumblebee co not covered,
rather by colored it was,
there was very clear black and
yellow stripes of all this thing,
like very bright,
intense black and very bright,
intense yellow.
And it was moving and like,
like,
and I was shooting down
this thing and then it was,
it was saying do not give into
astonishment and it was the word,
the words of Mckenna but not in,
you know,
like it wasn't,
I don't think I was his voice.
I think it was like no voice.
I think it was just the word that thought.
Well that's the weird thing about the,
the,
the telepathic thing that you,
you get from the DMT experiences.
You understand the words,
it's speaking to you in English,
but it's not really speaking to you.
It's just those things are getting
into your brain very clearly,
but I'm not really sure you hear them.
Yeah.
I mean,
here is a,
here is an experience,
which I'm,
well,
what a pity to go through life
and not have that experience ever.
Yeah.
I've said to many people like you,
you're screwing yourself,
man.
You're really,
it's,
it's scary as shit,
but boy,
do you get a lot out of them.
Yeah.
And I mean,
in my,
in my case,
the previous,
most of the previous DMT Giannis I'd had,
had not been terrifying.
They had been gentle and healing and nice.
I think that I was at a juncture in my
life where I needed to make a change.
And I think that that particular DMT
experience followed by the five Iowasca
journeys helped me to make that change.
And I'm,
I'm eternally grateful for that.
It was,
it was a really positive and
beneficial thing for them.
Yeah.
It was very positive and
beneficial for me as well.
Um,
I was,
I think I've always wanted a change.
Well,
I want to change now.
I mean I always want more,
more enlightenment,
more police,
more,
more serenity,
whatever it is.
Yep.
Um,
and the,
at the,
at that time,
I think what I was just trying to
figure out what are the possibilities,
what else is out there?
And it was just this one
big rush of impossible
possibilities and that redefined
my view of reality itself.
It was really scary though.
The last one was really slippery
because after it was over,
it was so intense and powerful that
regular reality didn't seem real to me.
And I was,
I was,
I went through a period where I feel like
my ego was trying to trick me by being
scared of everything was scared of car
accidents and trees falling in front of
my car and buildings
collapsing and earthquakes.
There's all these thoughts that came
into my mind that I just went on for four
days after the Chinese.
Yeah.
Not,
it's not intensely strong.
It wasn't like paranoia or um,
excuse me.
Um,
or anxiety.
It was like this flittering
thing that I'd go,
no,
stop it.
Stop it.
Right.
But like I'd be on the
highway and I'd be like,
what if this guy just fucking flips the
fucking road and it comes right towards
you and smashed his head on the,
your car,
your dad and all.
It was all this nonsense that
was just entering into my mind.
And it's not just being aware
of traffic and being smart,
but possibilities would.
And I think when a new,
I haven't been doing that before.
Never.
No,
never.
Okay.
I think what it was was my ego trying
to regain some sort of control.
Is that my ego by protecting me or by
keeping me paranoid and keeping me very
base and primal and animalistic,
worried about safety and shelter
and disasters and things like that.
It was trying to regain some strength
because it was so humbled by the
experience as a humbling experience.
Really.
It really is.
It's one of the most,
perhaps the most humbling
experience that is,
that it's possible to have.
And again,
that's why.
That's why it's valuable and and who says
we shouldn't have experiences because
they're scary,
you know,
these are amongst the most important
experiences it's possible to have.
I hear you use flotation tanks?
Yeah.
How many of my basement you have a,
do you use it regularly?
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
I've been using them for a I.
I bought my house in 2003 so,
so for,
for more than 10 years,
I've had this in my basement.
Please describe the extent to me.
You get you get into this.
We've never done it.
I've never done.
Oh my God,
I want to do it.
Where are you staying
while you're out here?
I was thinking money.
Food with friends.
Oh it perfect.
I'll get you in if you
want to go tomorrow.
Okay.
There's a place in Venice
called the float lab,
also the best place in the country and
you just go in there and float ass.
It's amazing.
You don't need anything.
I'd like to do two hours.
Okay.
If I have two hours,
but if I only have an hour,
I'll set a timer and I'll
put a timer outside of the,
uh,
the box so I can hear it when it goes off.
But uh,
that's my old one.
You see it up there.
That's my,
that's a Samadi tank that I had.
The one that I have now though
is built by the float lab,
which is far more complicated.
It's a really immense,
huge seven feet tall,
nine feet wide or nine foot long,
six foot wide.
It's huge.
It's like a,
it looks like a walk in freezer.
Okay.
And it has oxygen pumped into it.
When you're in it,
you're in water,
right?
There's salt water to keeps you,
keeps you suspension.
Do you have a done,
we're going to change your life tomorrow.
It's amazing.
It's like a psychedelic experience
except completely natural.
Completely safe.
And you can end it anytime you want,
but that's my new tank.
But when you,
when you climb into that thing,
the water is set to the same temperature
as the surface of your skin and there's
a thousand pounds of salt in that water.
It used to be 800 in my smaller tank or
this one's a thousand and so you can't
sync.
Exactly.
It's about 11 inches deep.
So even if you did sank
and you can't fall down,
you're fine and you're floating.
Like the half of your body is above
the water and as you live there,
you're in total silence,
total darkness.
Your ears are actually underwater.
You close the lid on this thing
and you don't hear a thing,
you don't see a thing,
you have no input and you don't feel
the water because the water is the same
temperature,
your skin,
so you're floating completely weightless.
It's really great for your body.
It feels great because you,
you would leave V8 all the
pressures of gravity and stress,
you feel your muscles
relaxing and unwinding.
And you,
for me,
the way I describe it as
the first 20 minutes or so,
it seems like a seminar on my life.
It gets me to start examining various
aspects of the stuff that goes through
like a life review in the
absence of sensory input.
You know,
like even while we're
having this conversation,
it's very quiet in the air,
but we're,
we're having to deal with the fact
that there's computers or screens,
ceiling.
There's your bud is chair.
Yup.
All those things are gone
in that tank and the tank,
it's just your mind.
It's the only place ever,
the only environment on earth where
your mind is untethered from your body.
It's an amazing,
amazing experience and completely safe,
completely natural,
completely beneficial,
completely refreshing.
It's amazing.
Even if you're not into the
psychedelic aspect of it,
you just want to relax.
It's incredible.
I love it.
It should be something that
everyone has in their home,
right.
It would benefit so many
people in so many ways.
Do you get into visionary space?
Absolutely.
Especially when you're going
and little smoker smoking.
But that's say the experience was,
it said no shows mushrooms enhance it.
Um,
uh,
but although a mushrooms are,
it's scary in there.
Uh,
I like cannabis,
cannabis,
eating cannabis is my favorite.
I like to eat enough cannabis that I feel
like I fucked up and ate too much and
then get in there.
Right.
That's the about those,
and those are intensely
psychedelic and very visionary.
But what I like about it is you can
end it pretty much at any moment.
Yeah.
And when you open the door,
you,
you'll use the cannabis will still affect,
you still have the weirdness of that,
but all the nutty hallucinations
and visuals will all go away.
You just step out.
Yeah.
You just step out and you can get to
that place without the cannabis as well.
I know a lot of people that have really
intense psychedelic visions while
they're in the isolation tank.
Interesting.
Well,
this is an experience I have to have.
You've got to have it.
You're going to have it tomorrow.
Do you have a day off or you're
afraid you don't have a total day off?
But I can get two hours.
Okay.
It will work it in and we'll make it.
We'll make it happen.
All right.
Um,
crash.
Who's the guy who runs the float lab
in Venice is a great friend and a great
guy.
He's a genius.
He's,
he's the wizard behind the curtain that
creates the greatest tanks on earth.
He's just nutty,
nutty dude that I just worked incredibly
hard to figure out a way to make.
There's like,
there's his,
there's tanks,
there's like this somebody tank,
which is a very good tank,
very functional.
You can use it.
There's a bunch of different companies
that have tanks and then there's his tank
and the difference is like a modern
BMW compared to a model t Ford.
Okay.
Like literally it's that good.
Oh,
it's amazing.
He's a,
he's just a genius.
He's,
he figured out a way to
pump oxygen into them.
He also figured out a way to
flush all the water through ozone.
It kills all the bacteria.
He has like incredibly
intense filtration systems.
Four and five step processes
are filtering the water,
like all of his equipment that he
has attached to all this stuff.
Nobody's rocking it like that.
I mean,
he takes it too literally.
Then he,
the next level is not
even a mile from him.
He's,
he's gone.
He's on a,
he's in a place all by his own with
what he's creating at the fund.
You're in total silence.
Total silence.
Total dog.
Total darkness.
And you don't feel a thing.
You feel like you're flying through
space because your body is completely
weightless.
It's the weirdest feeling ever,
but it's amazing.
You've convinced me.
Oh,
I can't believe you haven't done it,
but you're such a psychedelic adventure.
I would have thought that a
been a part of your daily life.
It hasn't been with it.
We've got to set you
up with one in England,
man.
We've got to send one over there and,
okay,
send,
crash over.
Have them set you up in
your basement or something.
It's,
I wouldn't live in a house if
I didn't have space for one.
Right.
Literally,
it's that important to you.
To me it's massive.
Anytime I've got something I'm thinking
about or trying to work on or or,
or,
you know,
new material and ideas,
I go,
I go through Jujitsu,
moves in there,
I go through scenarios,
I'll,
I'll visually spar.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
It's,
it's,
you don't get an opportunity to have
the mind at its full resource capacity
other than in that tank.
And this world constantly bombarding
sensation of all kinds were torn apart and
they can't wait to talk to you.
You get out.
Have you seen this new skull that they
found the 1.8 million year old human
skull?
No.
Yeah.
This is a amazing
discovery that they found.
Um,
this,
uh,
first completely preserved and we
see the Gulf commented from the early
Pleistocene.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
See if you could pull that up Jamie.
It's 1.8 million year old skull.
Um,
but it's,
it's,
it's a really amazing find and um,
they found it in Georgia and the eastern
Europe and it's the fifth such skull
from this region,
but it's 1.8 million years old.
That's really old.
That is,
um,
that is a,
there it is.
Let me see what they have.
Any still images of it,
but uh,
these,
uh,
they're,
they're completely,
it's thrown a gigantic monkey
wrench into our timeline of,
of human evolution.
They found stone tools and
cut marks on animal bones,
which indicates that the hominids were
actively involved in meat processing.
This is amazing,
but is it a,
is it a recognizable species
of early man has quite
prominent brow ridges?
It's um,
well it's,
it's some sort of early man,
um,
what they're calling it.
Let's see what they,
uh,
what they're calling it.
They haven't,
it hasn't received a name yet.
Have they wanted to kill Lucy?
And any idea about the size of the brain?
Um,
that's a good question.
They're calling it
golf five.
It says your skull five is different,
different even in the,
for the skulls found in a
demand to seize the name.
The area is found a 2005 and completely
and ultimately matched at jaw found in
2000 to make a complete skull.
After eight years of study,
scientists on Thursday published a paper
in the Journal of Science revealing
that skull five.
It's simply not that
different from others.
The five demand demand Hussey individuals
are no more different from each other
than any five modern humans.
Or chimpanzees said,
neurobiologists blah,
blah,
blah.
So the,
the brain case itself is very small
around the third of the size of modern
humans.
Okay.
And at the same time or for quite large?
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure I'd need to read it.
I'm not sure how much
that changes history.
I mean,
we know that there were
human species around one,
1.8,
1.9 the,
our ancestors were making tools
two and a half million years ago.
Uh,
so this is,
um,
this is well within that,
well,
within the time frame,
I think what maybe what it's showing
us is that there've been many lines of
human,
um,
down,
down through the ages and like,
like this one that they called the Hobbit,
you know,
Florida into tiny little creature,
which lived until 18 or 16,000
years ago and florists in,
in Indonesia.
Um,
that was completely unpredicted as well.
Then maybe there'd been many human types
and we don't know where we actually
come from in this whole,
in this whole picture.
Yeah.
These last hominids that
they keep discovering like
homo floresiensis and like
that a Russian one that they
found that was a basically 40,000
is all the completely different,
completely defeat the Soviet.
Yes.
Fascinating,
fascinating stuff.
And 40,000 years ago,
a blink of an eye blink of an eye.
Nothing.
Yeah,
just a completely different type of human.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
again,
what it adds up to is the
realization that we know nothing.
Actually.
We,
we'd,
we know very little.
We come out of mystery,
we live in mystery and we end in mystery.
Have you heard of the Orang?
Pendek yes.
This is cryptozoology.
What Lazier.
That's what my wife comes
from Malaysia and they,
and it's a kind of Yeti Malaysian
Yeti or Malaysia and big foot.
It's tiny,
but,
but uh,
but it's a,
it's a wild creature man,
like creature that lives
into the lives in the woods.
Well,
very similar to Homo
Floria and homophobia is,
and so the suggestion is Orang Pendek
is homo floresiensis or whatever it's
called.
He's still alive,
hanging out in the world.
It would sound ridiculous.
But this
homo,
what it was called,
Hobbit,
man,
this hobbit man was only 13,
14,000 years ago.
Very recently within the,
the span almost of human history.
I mean go Beckley Tappi and take you
where I've just been as 12,000 plus years
old.
Yeah.
Making these massive,
great megalithic pillars there.
So this creature on Flores is,
um,
just that period,
just the same,
the same age as that.
So the world was,
was filled with,
with all kinds of different creatures.
By the way,
on talking about Indonesia,
I'm going to Indonesia
on the 3rd of December,
um,
because there's been a new
site or rather an old site,
which has been radically
redated in Indonesia,
which is called Gunung Padang,
not that far from florists.
As a matter of fact,
uh,
it's a megalithic site with,
with gigantic basle columns.
And,
uh,
this place has been known
since the early 20th century,
thought to be about
three or 4,000 years old.
But there's an Australian
geologists called Danny Hilman,
who's been working for the Indonesian
government on a site survey for the last
five years.
And he's just in the last month or two
come out with this explosive finding that
he thinks this site is possibly
as much as 20,000 years old,
which a Megalithic site,
20,000 years old.
That completely rewrites history.
Go back,
leave Tapi already pretty
much rewrites history.
But this place in
Indonesia totally does it.
And when you take the two together,
so I'm,
I'm going to go out and take a look
at that site and meet Danny Hilman.
What is the name of it again?
Can you spell Pedang?
Whoa,
good on padding.
I may be able to show you a picture of it.
Jamie.
Put it up right?
It's going to be padding.
Yeah,
that is totally good.
And padding.
I used that picture.
So all these stones and what made
them date this to 20,000 years?
What was the chase?
So the previous dating has just been
based on the surface layers and Danny
Hilleman and his team had been down
deep into this manmade hill on on top of
which the surface layer stand and they've,
and they've gone all the way down and
they're finding big megaliths right down
at the bottom and they're finding
associated carbon that that allows them to
date it to up to 20,000 years old.
So this is a,
I mean this is a real huge game
changer that was taking place there.
So when they dated,
when they carbon dated
down to 20,000 years old,
is it based on organic material?
That has to be,
you can't cause you can't date,
you can't date stone,
but what you do is you get
into undisturbed layers
deep down in that manmade
hill that we're looking at
on the screen right now,
you get down into undisturbed layers
where you're finding megaliths at the
bottom covered,
covered by earth,
being covered by earth for 20,000 years.
And amongst that earth
is organic material,
fragments of bone,
fragments of charcoal that you
can date with carbon dating.
So you can then say that those
megaliths are at least that old,
at least,
at least most likely,
much older,
maybe much older than that,
but they're at least that old.
And the weird thing with this that this
place has in common with Gabelli Tapi is
that both of them are manmade hills,
which appeared to have had some kind of
deliberate burial of the earlier layers,
like a,
like a time capsule show.
I get this feeling that,
you know,
stuff is um,
stuff is out.
Uh,
stuff is a stuff is coming out into the
open that's been been suppressed for a
long time or,
or ignored or just not,
not reckoned with for a very,
for a very long time.
Well,
go back Lee tabby was a real game changer
because that was the first time that
they had found anything that you had
to date back to at least 12,000 years.
Go back,
go back to the happy is really,
really important.
And that's why I was,
I was glad to be able to go there in
September and spent a lot of time just
gently getting to getting
to know this site.
The reason,
the reason it's important is
because it was deliberately buried.
Um,
and,
and what it raises is,
uh,
I just want to show you this
cover from New Scientist magazine.
Can we,
can we show this?
Sure.
There it is.
The true dawn that we get that up there.
We'll,
we'll pull it up or have Jamie pull it up.
Civilization is older and more
mysterious than we thought.
Wow.
New Systems,
New Scientist magazine in
the beginning of October,
2013 now new scientists was,
what are the magazines that attacked me
massively back in 1995 when I publish
fingerprints of the Gods and what did
I say is in fingerprints of the gods.
Civilization is much older and much more
mysterious than we thought and now they
come out with this cover,
you know,
so I got to feel a certain,
a certain feeling of,
ah,
I dunno.
Almost smugness.
Oh yeah,
sure.
You can hear your voice.
You just get all giddy.
It's fun.
It's fun to see them doing that.
And the reason they're saying that is
I've got a lot to do with Rebecca tappy
because,
because go Beckley Tapi is that,
it's something completely
unpredicted that,
that what are supposed to be a hunter
gatherers at the end of the Upper
Paleolithic or not supposed to have
the kind of organizational skills,
the architectural skills to put
together gigantic megalithic circles.
There's one of the,
one of the pillows that I
went and took a look at,
which they didn't,
they never removed it from the quarry
because they found a fault in it.
Um,
it wasn't that they couldn't remove it,
they found a fault in it,
and that one weighs
more than fifth 50 tons,
you know,
as a judge.
Just a gigantic piece of stone.
And the other intriguing
thing about correctly,
Tefi is a,
which I learned from plush
Schmidt when I was talking to him,
is they've done ground penetrating radar.
So right now when you go to the side,
you see for substantial stone circles
on the scale of Stonehenge above ground
because you put the microphone costs,
sorry.
Yeah,
when you go,
when you go to go back to the Tempe,
now you see it,
you see a group of stone circles,
four of them above,
above ground.
There it is there.
And,
and,
um,
uh,
what they've done is they've done ground
penetrating radar over the site and
they found that at least 20 times as
many stone circles are still underground
and possibly as many as 50 times as many.
So it's a just a gigantic site.
And,
and why it's important is that
whoever made it 12,000 years ago,
deliberately buried it 2000 years later,
10,000 years ago.
So that meant that the carbon dating
record has not been contaminated by later
cultures.
It's a perfect pristine time capsule.
And Lo and behold,
the date that it prints
out is 12,000 years old.
Um,
now that then raises questions over lots
of other megalithic sites all over the
world,
which have been contaminated
by later cultures.
The megalithic sites of Malta,
for example,
look very like go back the Tempe,
they look very likability.
Tempe,
but they're only supposed
to be 5,000 years old.
I would now say we need to reconsider
that evidence because those sites were
contaminated by later culture.
Maybe the carbon on which they were
dated was introduced by a later culture.
Maybe it doesn't belong to the,
the period of the
construction of the megaliths.
Um,
well,
this alone,
this one,
discovery alone really is a huge game
changer because now we know that people
were capable of doing something
like that 12,000 years ago and,
and,
and not,
and not a task to be
underestimated because you're,
you're in an area where there
isn't a lot of water available.
So you,
you,
you're bringing in hundreds of people.
You're organizing them into teams to
construct these gigantic male ethics
circles.
You're feeding them,
you're watering them.
Uh,
your hat,
you have site planning and arrangement.
All of this is the kind of stuff that
you expect much later in human history.
You don't expect it 12,000 years ago.
And it raises that big question,
you know,
could there,
could there have been a lost civilization?
Could we be looking at the work,
perhaps of the survivors
of a lost civilization?
How do we know that they
covered it intentionally?
Um,
there's a,
there's a deliberate infill,
the nature of the,
of the earth that's been put into it.
You can pretty much say here where people
with spades pouring this earth in all
in one girl filling it in and
amongst the earth there are bits,
they're fragments of bone,
there a fragrance of carbon.
And that's how they've,
that's how they've dated it.
It's not,
it's not a,
it's not a natural sedimentation that
built up over a long period of time.
It's a,
it's something that was done all at
once in a planned and organized way.
So for some reason,
and the collage,
Schmidt,
the,
the German archaeologist who's running
the site is not clear what this reason
was.
For some reason,
whoever created this place,
decommissioned it at a certain point,
about 10,000 years ago,
they closed it down
and then this is eerie.
For the next 10,000 years,
it remained untouched and
nobody went there and nobody,
nobody saw it back in the 50s.
Some American archeologists
were attracted to the site,
they saw bits of cut stone lying on the
surface and the cut stone was so good
that they concluded it was recent.
They thought it must be
from the Ottoman period,
uh,
you know,
15,
1600,
something like that.
Uh,
and,
and they,
they ignored it.
And it was a really a lucky turn
of the spade by Klaus Schmidt,
this,
this German archeologists that revealed
that that's not the case at all.
And that these are 12,000
year old megalithic pillars.
And not only that,
so we have this incredible innovation
in architecture taking place,
stone circles on the scale of Stonehenge,
but 7,000 years earlier than Stonehenge
being created it correctly Tempe.
But at the same time,
mysteriously agriculture
starts to appear in that area.
There hasn't been agriculture there
before or anywhere so far as we know.
And suddenly it starts to appear there.
Domesticating cattle there,
domesticating wheat,
uh,
and,
beginning.
This is the beginning of
the agricultural revolution.
So it's like a center of innovation,
uh,
that we do it,
that we're doing something unique
as far as we know in human history,
in terms of architecture.
We're doing something unique in terms
of economics producing the first,
the first agriculture and I,
I can't help feeling that the,
that this thing happens so suddenly and
in such an extraordinary way that maybe,
maybe this is the,
the missing link that we are looking at.
We're looking at the fingerprints
of a lost civilization,
the survivors of a lost civilization
who settled there with all these skills
already in place and introduce them into
the local culture because this period,
12,000 years ago plus is the period
when the earth went through gigantic
cataclysmic events because
it was struck by a comment.
Yeah.
And that's the,
uh,
that's the other piece of the puzzle.
The nuclear glass that they've found.
How do you say to stop trying,
try night tight,
trinet tight trinet,
trinet tight and that they
have found this stuff all over.
Yeah.
Or Europe
and all over Asia,
all over the world at that precise,
precise 12,000 years ago,
layer of platinum in
the Greenland ice cores.
All of this says Earth was hit by a,
by a comet at that,
at that time.
Is that the Holocene?
Well,
that's the beginning of this.
The end of the,
it's the beginning of the Holocene.
The Holocene is our period is
the period we still live in now.
But it's the,
in in archeological terms,
it's the juncture between the Upper
Paleolithic and the Neolithic.
That's,
that's what we're,
that's what we're talking about here.
Um,
and you have this episode that
geologists called the younger Dryas,
which is an episode of a sudden
a deep freeze strikes the earth.
The earth has been emerging from
the Ice Age until 12,980 years ago.
And Amazingly,
you can date it that precisely
give or take five years.
This happened 12,980 years ago.
And then suddenly the earth flips into
this thousand year deep freeze that
nobody's ever been able to explain before
that they called the younger dryas.
And now we can say for sure
that the younger dryas was
caused by huge amounts of
dust being projected into the upper
atmosphere of the earth by this comet
impact.
And that that dust in shrouded the whole
earth and set in motion a kind of what
we would call a nuclear winter today,
where,
where the sun's rays could no longer
reach the earth and the earth went back
into a deep freeze.
And for me,
this is the smoking gun that lost us,
the whole civilization.
And I was just,
uh,
yesterday I was,
I was,
uh,
I've come here from North Carolina and
I sat down with Randall Carlson who has
been a,
met him.
You met Randall is very,
very fascinating man and he's been
working away quietly on this subject for
years and years and years long before
the evidence was in for a comment,
he was predicting that
this is what caused it,
that there was a comment
impact and got this very,
very fascinating theory.
And he's going to take me next year on a,
on a field trip,
uh,
into the Pacific northwest
and into Canada to look at,
to look at areas where there were these
massive outflows of floods from the ice
cap.
And what Randall is suggesting is that
that at least some large fragments of the
comic that hit the Earth 12,980
years ago actually hit the ice cap.
They landed on the ice cap,
which was still in a mile
deep and they pulverize it.
They turned it into water immediately
and that's why you have these gigantic
outburst floods,
which carried down huge boulders
and strew them all over the,
all over the landscape is a very,
very exciting theory and it's,
and it's great to see Randall's work
being being vindicated because he's been
ignored for far too long.
And I'm,
I'm looking forward to doing a fascinating
field trip with him next next year.
I met him in Georgia many years ago.
The punchline comedy club had a long
and really interesting conversation
conversation about him with him
rather about the Holocene comment.
Yes.
Well,
that's exactly what he's talking about.
You see,
he's,
he's one of these guys who is just so
far ahead of his time that nobody saw it.
Nobody,
nobody realized what he was on.
Now everybody understands that the earth
was hit by a comet and there's been a
big scientific argument about this
over the last five or six years,
but it's really settled now.
The evidence that the
all over the world is,
is clear that this happened.
But Randall was onto this years before
anybody else and what he's done,
what he's also doing is just taking it,
taking it that bit further because we
have these mysterious floods that occurred
in precisely that period,
which have traditionally
been called outburst floods.
The idea was that,
um,
the,
the ice caps gradually melting down filled
up these huge glacial lakes and that
eventually the ice dam in
closing the grace place,
he'll lake would break.
But now it looks like we're looking at
ice dams a thousand feet high in order to
account for the massive flow of water.
And what Randall suggesting is
that that theory is actually wrong.
It wasn't the outburst
floods from Grace Hill legs.
It was the comet hitting the ice cap
that turned all that ice to water and
produce the gigantic gigantic
outflows carrying down boulders,
you know,
the size of houses and dumping
them over the landscapes and,
and then you have to consider anything
that lay in the way of those floods.
Anything that lay in the path
of floods on that scale is gone,
gone,
completely wiped out from human memory.
And you also have to consider the fact
that we absolutely know that these events
have taken place in a much greater scale.
Over the course of the earth
has been mass extinction events.
So this,
this is not preposterous.
There's not proposed to Roger.
It's completely logical and it's time
that historians and archeologists
abandoned the model that everything just
proceed smoothly and gently in the way
that we've seen it doing for
the last few hundred years,
which is called uniformitarianism and it,
and embrace the thought that that
cataclysmic events are a key part of the
history of the earth.
And,
and we should know this already,
there's massive amount of evidence for it.
It doesn't,
it's not something we even need to argue
about by history proceeds on the basis
that there is no such
thing as a cataclysm.
In fact,
it's cataclysms that have written
the story of human history.
Well,
not only that,
when you stop and look at all
the ancient stories of the epic,
of Gilgamesh,
the Bible,
the flood of the art.
Exactly.
There's so many stories and involve
cataclysmic events about floods and
cataclysms the idea that those are
just fiction has kind of sits totally.
He totally crazy and they
all say that this is a,
that there was a golden age,
that there was a former,
that there was a former civilization that,
that mankind had had,
had attained to a very high level
and then we angered the gods.
It's often put that way.
We,
we angered the gods,
we fell out of harmony with the universe.
There was,
um,
something went wrong.
There was some kind of moral,
yes,
please.
I would love some of that.
This is Phil.
Okay.
That one,
there was some kind of moral decline.
Like now,
like now,
like now this is what I,
what I,
I often say that if,
if I were to look at our civilization
in myths and mythical terms,
there's never been a civilization
that looked more like the next lost
civilization than ours.
I don't want to spread gloom and doom.
I don't believe in
spreading gloom and doom.
I think we should think positive.
And I have said earlier,
and I,
and I maintained this,
I'm very optimistic about
the future of the human race,
but let's not pretend that
it's all roses in the garden.
There's a terrible things are
happening in the world today.
We have an unbelievable
arrogance and unbelievable pride,
cruelty,
uh,
that,
an economic model that makes
millions mean countless millions,
incredibly poor,
and allows tiny,
tiny numbers to be incredibly,
obscenely rich.
Um,
and,
and the whole system is skewed
in the interest of that tiny,
tiny fraction of 1% of the wealthy.
And unfortunately,
it's really a,
as,
as bad as it's possible to get in America.
Um,
it's just bad in many other countries too,
but it's really bad in America.
The skewing of the skewing of wealth and,
and,
and the brainwashing of the
population to keep people quiet,
to stop people thinking the mind
control operates in our society.
It's like a pressure cooker.
Something's,
something's got to give.
And,
and,
and ours is a culture which is
literally destroying the earth.
I,
I the Amazon jungle,
this amazing sacred realm,
this incredible home of biodiversity,
this,
this beautiful,
beautiful place.
Uh,
the destruction that's taking place now,
only a society that is truly
insane could allow that to happen.
And that's unfortunately
our society today.
So we need to wake up
and you want to talk about the
writing on the wall as far as a,
a powerful,
advanced civilization being
completely wiped off the earth.
How about our writing is
all going to the cloud.
We have this,
this crazy trend where everything is
going into these databases and hard drives
and when those are destroyed,
there'll be nothing to hold on to.
Nothing to read.
All of our knowledge will be memory.
I mean it's almost ensuring
that there will be nothing
remaining total wipe out this side.
This idea that I've,
that I've talked about
many times over the years,
that we are a species with amnesia.
We are going to be a species
with Amnesia because again,
and our culture has not,
has not at all looked at the,
at oral traditions,
we've destroyed the oral tradition.
You know,
we've put everything into the written
form now beamed it up into the cloud and
uh,
one,
one disaster.
It's all gone.
And at least in a written
form you have books.
Yeah.
I mean we don't even have books anymore.
We have,
we have electronic updates.
It's just,
it's so crazy to think that all it takes
is one asteroidal impacts that wipes
out the grid and all that stuff's gone.
All that stuff,
he can't access it anymore.
You have to rebuild the entire power grid.
And if the future,
I mean,
if we lose one or two generations,
if we had a Holocene type incident again
or a big comment hit and wiped out 50%
of the population and we had to Sorta
refigure out databases and refigure out
hard drives,
we're not going to,
we're going to gather food and
we're gonna figure out agriculture.
We're going to figure out some
real primitive ways to live life.
But most of that stuff with three,
four generations later is gone.
It's gone,
gone completely,
completely gone.
And,
and,
um,
I mean we have these gigantic
populations now based in cities where,
where,
um,
actually the food supplies
incredibly fragile.
It's like two or three days of food
is available at any city at any time.
Um,
consider the implications of that
if that supply chain breaks down.
And we were very clear,
we're on record now.
Look what's just happened
in the Philippines.
Look at Hurricane,
Hurricane Katrina.
We cannot deal with natural disasters.
Big One too,
man.
That was a really,
really scary one that the Philippines
superstorm a storm the size of Germany,
you know,
believable thousands,
10,000 more more people killed and,
and very slow reactions to do,
to do anything about it.
We have very bad human rights.
We could oldest tech,
we got all this wealth,
we got all this complacency.
But actually when,
when the universe strikes us,
we are unable to do anything about it.
And,
and that's what's true in the
most wealthy country in the world.
In America as we saw
with Hurricane Katrina.
And this is three times bigger than
three times bigger than countries.
They showed some a city that was
200,000 people and there's not a single
structure left standing.
Yeah,
unbelievable.
Just,
and that,
by the way,
there have been bigger
ones had been bigger storms
throughout history than that.
There's been bigger impacts
than the Holocene one.
And the other thing about the
universe is that our orbit,
like where we are is stable
and we have the moon,
which helps our orbit but be still,
but there's hundreds of thousands of
near Earth objects that are just floating
around out there that
could easily come down,
collide into each other,
slamming the earth.
And that's a wrap.
Absolutely.
This,
this again is something is something
that needs to be taken very,
very seriously.
Again,
I want to say
let's emphasize the positive and
let's emphasize positive thinking,
but let's also be rational and reasonable.
And when you look at the orbits of near
Earth Asteroids called Apollo objects,
uh,
it's like looking at a cat's cradle a of
harm that is surrounding this precious
jewel of a,
of a,
of a planet.
And we don't even know them all.
We,
we know a tiny fraction of them.
What becomes clear is we only
know a little bit of these things.
Some of them 10 miles wide,
which are whinging through,
uh,
you know,
outer space and,
and can hit us at any time.
And then comments,
then comments,
some,
some comments can have 12,000 year orbits.
The suggestion that we're seeing a lot
of increased meteor activity as well
right now,
a lot of,
a lot of action going on.
And uh,
the suggestion,
and again,
rather castle's work has been really
important in this area is the torrid.
The tutorial,
um,
uh,
asteroid or comet,
the,
the toric shower is a remains
of a disintegrated comment.
And in that shower there
may be huge things,
the size of cities which are,
which are flowing through and crossing
the orbit of the earth regularly.
It's not just pretty pretty
little lights in the sky.
Uh,
one day,
one day we're going to run into something,
something the size of New York,
you know,
which is going to going to hit us.
So that,
so this is,
this is a matter of,
for,
for care and concern and,
and again,
look what we do.
You know,
we spent,
we spend billions,
trillions,
limitless,
endless amounts of money and inventing
new ways to destroy each other and very
little on actually looking at,
on how to,
how to protect the earth.
Could they protect the earth
or from something like that?
Well,
if we don't look into it,
we certainly won't have an
answer to that question.
Some of them don't.
They come from behind the sign and
we can't see them because of gravity.
You can't see them come.
They can't see them come back.
But if the kind of,
if the kind of focused scientific
effort that we're presently,
that is presently put into creating
weapons of mass destruction so that we can
all fight each other.
If that kind of effort we put into making
sure that we understand the orbit of
every single asteroid that's out there,
we identify them and find them,
well,
we'd be a lot safer than we are today.
There's no profit in that.
Graham Hancock and [inaudible]
our corporates stockholders to do.
That's ridiculous,
sir.
Yeah.
It's almost mimics this
cyclical nature of life itself.
It seems like civilization builds up to
this incredible point where it's like
completely out of control and just
reckless and wild and then boom,
gets knocked down and
then builds back up again.
And it's almost,
I'm not suggesting that these things
floating around in space are there for a
reason,
but if they were,
I mean it would be like
little reset buttons,
a little reset buttons.
I mean,
maybe that's what happened
when the dinosaurs got it,
got to a fly the,
that's why the ancient mythology,
which consistently says right or wrong,
consistently says that
mankind is implicated in these
cataclysms our behavior,
our wickedness is implicated
in this in some way.
I think it's worth listening
to that a little bit and,
and,
and you know,
maybe maybe this,
this,
this time we don't have
to go through the reset.
Maybe.
Maybe it's possible for mankind to
actually wake up now that we are globally
connected now that we do have this
possibility of all talking to one another
before it's too late,
we can reset ourselves
in a positive direction.
I feel like the only way we would
as if we knew something was coming,
I think that's almost the only way.
And we would have to be informed and
then we would have to believe it.
And then there would be disputes and I'm
sure the Republicans would start laughs
nonsense.
We're a show you right here at the
same scientist that brought you climate
change are telling you right now and
there's an asteroid hitting our rank.
Certainly they would.
They would.
They would say that she
just is going to protect us.
What we need to do is cut
taxes for corporations and
ensure that we can move to
Mexico and when our factories.
Yeah,
I wonder,
I wonder if we would really pay attention
if we knew that we had a year left.
If we had a year ago and they'd get that.
Think of that.
What a difference.
What a situation that would be.
Think of that.
We barely pay attention
to what we're doing.
That's really obvious.
Like the polluting of the ocean
or the the destroying of the,
the,
the pulling s.
There's the fish out of the ocean and
the alarming rate that doesn't allow them
to recover insane.
All of it about the pursuit
of short term profits,
all of it about immediate payoffs.
Nobody,
nobody thinking long term.
Again,
I come back to this.
We are a deranged society and,
and a little nodes of sanity are
beginning to wake up all around the world,
but maybe it's not,
not in enough time.
And isn't that,
doesn't it also go back to what you
were saying about psychedelics and how
beneficial psychedelics can be because
one of the main themes of Iowasca is save
the planet.
It's safe.
The planet.
It's a universal theme of Iowasca.
Sooner or later,
anybody who works with Iowasca enough is
going to start picking up that message
that this beautiful earth,
that we have,
this gift that the universe has given us,
his precious beyond measure,
precious beyond imagination and that
we are part of it and that we must,
we must treat it with love and respect
and reverence rather than in the,
in the horrific way that we do.
And that part of treating the planet
with love and respect and reverence is
treating fellow human beings with love
and respect and reference at every,
at every level.
This is a very strong message of Iowa.
Ask.
It is a message.
It is fundamentally a message of love,
not in a wishy washy way,
but in a really firm and clear way that
that is the salvation of the human race.
There's,
Bill Hicks said it,
you know,
the love is the opposite of fear.
Fear.
Fear is what is what
presses are buttons today.
It's what's used deliberately
depress our buttons.
And,
and what's the opposite of that is,
is love.
That's what we need.
And then Bill Hicks
did a lot of mushrooms.
Fox and Bill Hicks did a lot of
mushrooms and what a brilliant,
brilliant man he was.
Oh yeah.
He's one of my comedy heroes.
Yeah,
for sure.
There's a 19 year old inventor
who found a way to clean up
the world's ocean in
under five years time.
Um,
he,
he this great Pacific garbage patch.
This young kid has figured out this,
this machine that would a absorb all
the plastic material in the ocean.
Really fascinating stuff.
Um,
there's a,
there's an article about it,
uh,
on,
this is VR dashed zone.com.
But I'm sure if you do
a Google search on that,
you can find several different
sites that have covered that,
but it's like this is a machine that
would essentially sit in the center of the
ocean and start sucking
all the plastic up.
We have a huge,
huge,
huge problem with this.
This plastic in the ocean is something
that no one even considered until roughly
a decade or so ago when they started
being aware that all the stuff that were
littering on,
Eh,
you know,
whether it's throwing off a boat or
just finds its way to the ocean through
drainage pipes or what have you,
we're dealing with a massive,
massive amount of material and material
that's not biodegradable that's being
turned into like this sludgy sort of
shitty stuff that's floating around.
There's a kind of symbol of everything
that's wrong without culture actually.
Yeah,
it really is and it's,
and a bed bed is this guy's idea
going to be taken up as well.
Hopefully.
I mean,
it's pretty amazing that
this 19 year old kid,
well my,
the point being that what
I find fascinating is that
when our back is up against
the wall,
like when someone realizes,
oh my God,
we have this,
this country sized patch of,
of plastic that's floating
around in the ocean.
Yeah.
When your back is up against the wall,
people start thinking when
people start thinking,
they start innovating,
when they started innovating
solutions come about.
And maybe even a solution when they say,
hey,
you know what,
that plastic is actually,
you could turn that into
stuff that actually could be
used as fuel that actually
could be used to create things that
actually could be used in a beneficial way
that,
but then the problem is going to be how
do you keep people from continuing the
same process and re polluting it
again once you've cleaned it up.
Yup.
Psychedelics.
Yeah.
It won't be the only way.
The,
the,
the realization that the huge
kick up the ass that comes with,
uh,
with,
with a major responsibly
taken psychedelic journey.
And then there's also the challenge
of our current trend in these gigantic
cities and these gigantic
cities aren't sustainable.
They're not agriculturally sustainable,
sustainable.
So like how do you,
how do you,
how do you figure out a way to stop
the trend of these gigantic cities or
provide food or figure
out a way to be in a,
in a sustainable environment and still
have modern conveniences and technology
and medicine and all those,
you know,
very difficult,
very,
very difficult problem if possible,
how to solve.
But I'd like all of these gigantic
problems if we begin to solve them at a
personal level,
within our own sphere of influence within,
within where we live in our
relationships with other human beings.
So that's a good start.
That's,
that's where we do have power.
That's where we do have choice.
We cannot change the
world,
any one of us,
but we can change the way
we interact with others.
Yeah.
And it seems like that's probably the
best way to fix this whole masses.
To fix it on a macro
scale or a micro scale.
Micro scale.
Yeah.
Fix it in individuals and
spread it like a virus spread.
This new found realization
of what we're really doing,
what our impact really is,
the awareness and this
sort of new found idea of,
of connectivity that we have and that
we're starting to grasp a hold up because
of this internet culture,
because of this new area,
this new new new area in history,
this guy,
this new level of a,
of admission.
That's,
that's,
that's where it's happening.
And,
and that's,
that's where I take hope,
you know,
because I,
I meet young people every
time I go out and give a,
give a,
give a lecture,
give it,
give a talk,
I meet,
I meet young people who have come there
and they are thinking in a new way,
you know,
the old ideas of nationalism
and patriotism and all
that bullshit have gone.
These are people who are
thinking in terms of,
of humanity as a whole.
And,
and,
and thinking in terms of what a glorious
gift the universe has given us with
this planet.
And we have to live right there.
There is a tremendous
spirit in the world today.
Well,
one of the benefits of travel is that
travel sort of erodes the idea of
nationalism in a way where you meet
these people in these other countries and
you realize well they're just like me.
Just like they mean they might talk in a
different accent or a speak a different
language,
but they're just people.
And I think one of the reasons why people
have nationalism is based on a fear of
those other people.
Again,
fear is the theme and fear and this
is fear that can be manipulated,
that the powers that that run the
world at the moment are deliberately
manipulating all the time to divide us
from one another and prevent us from
realizing.
And amongst those powers are of course
all of the big states and government
apparatus and are of course
all of the big religions,
Christianity,
Judaism and Islam are all in
the theater business as well.
They're all in generating fear and
telling us that this is the only way to do
things and we are
different and this is the,
this is the right way to do things of
that is the wrong way to do things.
And that's the old model.
Uh,
the big corporations,
they are part of that too.
You know,
you have to rely on us.
We will be the answer to
your all your problems.
Such bullshit.
That's the old model.
And that's the,
that's the model that is bit by
bit day by day one step at a time,
one brick at a time getting replaced.
It's really is isn't it?
And the,
the,
the model of government itself is a
giant chunk of fear with a little bit of
hope.
And the hope is all lies.
No hope is all silly.
I mean the hope is basically bullshit
provided by corporations so they can keep
fracking.
You know,
it's like,
yeah,
the,
I honestly thought fracking,
you know?
Yeah.
All fear,
all fear,
fear,
fear generated.
Um,
and,
and this is what we,
what we need to move beyond government.
I think the way we've known it for
the last centuries on the way it,
what it's come to today,
it's done,
it's over.
It's stories over it.
It's hanging.
It's fucking
everything up as badly as it can.
But it is done.
That is,
that is a model that will no longer work
and whether or not it wants to or not,
it will slowly be phased out.
I think that when you're,
when you're talking about it,
what's interesting that I think that
the very practices that it's using right
now that our government is using
are going to aid its own demise.
The practices of the NSA
monitoring everybody's email and,
and constantly spying on Americans.
So ridiculous socially where people
are just like completely up in arms and
upset about it.
But also that technological trend
is going to lead to ultimate truth.
And that's a real issue
with the government because
the government relies on
deception and bullshit and bribery
and special interest groups.
Absolutely.
They can't keep that up if
you have ultimate truth,
ultimate access to information
and the boundaries between people,
that information are all gone.
Yeah.
How are you going to run a country?
The sow,
the seeds of their own destruction are,
are already planted in the
mechanisms they're putting in place.
Yeah.
It's like it's,
they can't,
it's like if you ever seen,
um,
there's a,
a method of hunting walls that the
Eskimos use where they would take a very
sharp knife and put it in the ground and
put blood on the knife and a wolf would
come along and start to lick the knife
because of the blood on the knife,
taste his own blood and continued to lick
and bite the blade and bleed to death.
I didn't know that.
That's a story that actually happens.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's a method that they,
the,
the nun people devised of hunting roles,
they would plant these knives in the ice
and that's what our government's does.
Exactly.
They're there.
They're licking their own blood
and they don't even realize it.
But these things,
like the perfect example is,
I don't know if you know the story in
our country of General Petraeus who was
the head of the CIA,
was exposed through the head of the CIA.
Is that,
that's supposedly the number
one spy in the country,
right?
That's the head.
Well,
he he was,
he was fired because it was exposed that
he was having an affair and that affair
x fair was a s exposed
through email exchanges.
Right.
When the FBI examined the CIA,
the FBI is ratting on the CIA and getting
rid of the number one CIA guy through
email,
through a transparency
and email exchanges.
Absolutely.
Completely fascinating.
It is.
It is because it's that this is the,
this is the main government
entity that's involved in spine,
you know,
other than the NSA and it's just,
it all like you guys are
going to get exposed to,
everyone's going to get exposed
is getting exposed and the,
the real problem isn't in affairs.
I mean affairs are obviously are an issue,
but the real problem is going to be in
the structure of power itself and what
the influence is so clearly
exposed the influence,
whether it's a special interest
groups of corporations,
of lobbyists,
whatever it is,
when it's so clearly exposed
that it cannot be tolerated
by rational people bear
it anymore.
There's this growing
anger about all of this.
This is what the what the,
the in the people
in big government who are,
who are advocating this
continual surveillance and
invasion of our privacy in
every,
in every possible way.
They're not getting the anger in society.
People like just not prepared to
put up with this shit any longer.
And I think it's a great thing because
I think there's nothing wrong with
government.
There's nothing wrong with having a mayor.
There's nothing wrong
with having a president.
There's nothing wrong with police as long
as everyone's honest and rational and
ethical truth is the key.
And they'll be forced to do that.
It's not like we're advocating that the
government needs to be destroyed and
anarchy nonsense.
We want honest government,
completely truth possible.
And if it's forced then then,
then it's forced.
But if it's forced because of technology
and innovation instead of some crazy
radical violent revolution,
it's just as powerful,
just as powerful to change.
In fact,
California and undeniable,
yeah.
Can't just build up a wall
to keep the Internet out.
No,
no,
no.
Definitely.
Definitely not know the truth.
The truth is the truth is key.
This is what matters.
And also also those who go,
who,
who go into into government.
They shouldn't be,
they shouldn't be this huge status
and power associated with it.
You know?
It's a,
it's a,
it's a mistake.
It should be.
It should be done.
It should be the person who
doesn't want to go into government.
That's the person who
should be in government.
Yeah.
It's unfortunate that that is how,
how it's been for a long time.
It's the people that should,
shouldn't be president of the
ones that want to be present.
It's been that way for a long time.
Give them Iowasca.
I would hope and I would hope
also that the trend is moving.
I mean,
if you go back to these people that we're
talking about that existed these pre
humans that existed 1.8 million years ago,
and the way they conducted each other,
conducted their lives,
and then look at how we conduct our
lives in 2013 it's been a massive,
incredible amount of progress
and understanding each
other that this trend will
continue and if we don't get
hit by some kind of giant media,
that we will ultimately reach a level
of understanding that will sort of make
this happen.
Whether or not psychedelics
are involved or not,
that we'll,
we'll just reach this level.
As I say,
it's happening.
It's happening,
it's happening now.
It's interesting that
psychedelics are a catalyst in it.
Um,
the,
the come up again and again in the
conversation and what it boils down to is
the,
the recognition,
and I've been banging on about
this for a long time there,
the recognition of,
of the adult sovereign individual that
we have a right to explore our own
consciousness.
That is a grotesque invasion of our
privacy and our sovereignty over our own
bodies that a government would,
would even have the temerity to suggest
that it's got a right to punish us for
doing that.
This,
this is the,
it's not the issue of the
psychedelics themselves.
It's the issue of the right
to make sovereign decisions
about our own bodies and
our own consciousness.
And this,
I see a big awakening all
over the world taking place,
Litmus test.
I agree.
And it's,
it's one of those things where we're
going to look back on through history and
the way we look at the inquisition,
the way we look at burning witches were
we're going to look at the prosecution
of people for using psychedelics.
And it's just as ridiculous
with horror as a,
as a,
as a horrific episode when human
society made terrible mistakes.
Your book supernatural
is a fascinating book.
I really enjoyed that.
And that details the,
the concept of human beings learning
from psychedelic experiences and actually
it giving birth to a new level of
creativity and a new level of culture.
I believe that,
uh,
that there's,
there's no doubt that psychedelics have
played a huge unrecognized role in the
human story.
And I want to pay tribute to Terence
Mckenna for being one of the early people
to recognize that again,
in so many ways,
Terence mckenna,
just an incredible genius,
uh,
that stoned ape theory that,
that,
that he came up with is
absolutely key to this.
And again,
he was far ahead of his time
academics followed behind him in this,
in this that we need to recognize that
these demonized plants have played a huge
role in the human story.
Just in my recent
travels in South America,
I was in a place called corral a 200,
200 kilometers north of Lima in Peru.
Um,
now back in the 90s,
people were saying that there was no,
that could be no relationship between
old world pyramids and New World Pyramids
because all the pyramids in the
new world were much younger.
That story is now gone as a result of
chorale and another site ban Doria in
Peru,
which are definitively 2,500 to 3000 BC,
the same date that is put on the,
the Great Pyramids of Giza.
And what's fascinating at
Caroll is a couple of things.
Firstly,
there was a big city complex there 5,000
years ago and absolutely no evidence of
warfare whatsoever.
It was traditionally it was believed that,
you know,
the evolution of cities was connected
with warfare in some way that people came
in to cities to protect
themselves from war.
No warfare,
none whatsoever.
These people did not make war.
Secondly,
they were using psychedelics,
um,
quite clear evidence of this.
Uh,
so you know,
this unexamined part of the human story
needs to be brought back into prominence
and we need to realize we owe a lot to
the visionary plants and we're making a
mistake to create a
society that seeks to cut,
cut us off from that source of
learning and that source of teaching.
It's not an accident in the Amazon
that they call these plants teachers.
They are teachers.
And I think it's also
very fascinating that the,
the academic world has in many ways,
in many ways,
especially the older academic world
that grew up without the internet,
has turned their back on the concept
of psychedelics being beneficial to the
point where it's laughed at and Poo
pooed to the point where it Mckenna's
Psychedelic,
a stoned ape theory is if
you don't know the theory,
his theory involves the
evolution of humans,
the doubling of the human brain size
directly related to the consumption of
psychedelic mushrooms.
It's an incredibly controversial theory,
but when I had Dennis
Mckenna on the podcast,
Dennis explained it in a very scientific
way that would show how the psych,
the
consumption of psychedelic mushrooms
would correlate with the creating of
language,
with the expansion of consciousness.
It's,
it's an incredibly intricate and detailed
idea that's completely ignored by so
many mainstream people,
but if they have had,
excuse me,
if they have had any psychedelic
experience themselves,
they would know what an incredibly
different experience that is.
Then the normal state of consciousness.
If you were looking for a culprit,
a thing that would change conscious
beings or intelligent beings like lower
hominids,
something that would just rock
them out of their current state.
What better thing than,
than psychedelic trucks?
What other culprits that
you could connect to?
A doubling of the human brain size?
I've seen it attributed to a bunch of
different things like consumption of fish,
uh,
through the throwing arm,
all these different things
like don't bears eat fish,
not these stupid as fuck.
I guess the Omega threes
would help a little,
but man,
what's humans are a different thing
that humans are very different thing.
And,
and uh,
yeah,
I mean I have,
I have no doubt in my mind it was
psychedelics that played that role.
And this was one thing
that I looked at in,
in,
in supernatural was,
was this whole issue of the
cave art because that's where,
you know,
that's where in the long evolutionary
story of the human species,
you suddenly find us
confronting ourselves.
We're looking at this
amazing symbolic art,
this incredible,
incredible works.
Um,
and these very mysterious Erie spaces
that you go into like the Cape of Lesko.
Um,
and,
uh,
from the nature of the art itself,
it's clear it was visionary art.
These were,
these were people who were working with
psychedelics and painting their visions
just as Sherman's doing the Amazon today.
Did you see Werner Herzog's documentary?
I did cave of a shy dreams about Chavon.
Yeah.
I mean it wasn't that like
40,000 plus years ago.
The stuff 33 or 33,000 years
ago gave a show bay amazing,
amazing place.
Yeah.
Just so strange to think that these Pete,
but it's so hard for us to,
when you get to a number,
even a thousand years,
it's like I can't see it.
I can't,
it's too far away.
It's almost like it's over
the curve of the earth.
It's like a thousand years to wrap my
head around what it was like during the
[inaudible] era,
you know,
nevermind 33,000.
Yeah.
That's where it gets
like incredibly squirly.
And when you talk to guys
like John Anthony West,
it started talking about the hieroglyphs
that depict a civil is ancient and not
just that,
but named the Pharaohs of
30 plus thousand years ago.
It's loosely,
there's a,
I mean this is something that
really annoys me about Egypt.
[inaudible] John Anthony West
is just such a brilliant man.
He's an old,
old friend of mine going
wait way back to the 90s.
Super,
Super Guy and he's done so much to,
to bring to light the mysteries and the,
and the magic of,
of ancient Egypt.
And he's absolutely right because
you go to the temple of Seti,
the first and the avatars
and you will see a mural,
a cop in high relief
on,
on a wall in the Cardo was shows,
uh,
the pharaoh Seti,
the first showing his young
son Ramesses the second,
the list of all the pharaohs
who've ruled before their time.
Now this is called a king list.
And the Egyptologists,
they take these king lists and they use
them as the basis for the chronology
that we are given of ancient Egypt.
As long as it fits into
their reference frame.
So the king list is,
is fine.
It's accepted back to 3000 BC.
The first dentisty when civilization
is supposed to have begun,
they then completely ignore the fact
that the king list continues long before
that for tens of thousands of years,
as much as 36,000 years before that lists
of pharaohs and the time when the gods
walked the earth.
All of this is in the king lists as well.
So the fee,
you know,
the Egyptologist grab the bit that fits
their prejudice and ignore the rest and
say,
I will.
The ancient Egyptians
were just making that up.
Yeah.
And then there's of course the water
erosion on the Sphinx that John Anthony
West and Robert Schoch exposure actually.
So really,
in my opinion,
one of the most undeniable things
that I've heard people deny.
Yeah.
It's one,
it's one of the most of it is one of the
most important pieces of evidence for a
lost civilization.
It,
and,
and this is John Anthony
West and professor Robert
Schoch at Boston University.
The,
the,
the evidence that the Great Sphinx was
rained upon for thousands and thousands
of years.
Now,
what's,
what's interesting,
and again got Beckley,
he comes into this story,
is that Egypt ologists at the time said,
look,
there's no way that the Sphinx
could be 12,000 years old.
The geological evidence must be wrong
because if there was a culture that was
capable of creating a monument on the
scale of the Sphinx 12,000 years ago,
well,
why?
We would find other monuments
that are 12,000 years old,
other big monuments.
And they regarded that as the killer
argument against the geological weathering
of this thing.
So that you know,
that shock and West must just be wrong.
Well,
now we have good Beckley Tempe and it is
12,000 years old and it is on the scale
of this things.
And it's not even that
far from this things,
you know,
and suddenly the,
the,
that old argument about the Sphinx,
which was dismissed by
academia back in the 90s,
they're going to have
to reconsider it very,
very,
very carefully.
That Charlton Heston hosted
documentary on the Sphinx,
which was,
I believe it was on NBC.
It was on NBC.
I watched it.
I found an incredibly fascinating
but in infuriating when you hear that
Egyptologist just laughing
at Robert Schoch saying,
where's the evidence of this culture?
Show me the pot shit.
Yeah.
And what's crazy is,
what do you think would be there when
you're dealing with something that's that
old?
Yeah,
and when,
as I said,
about a thousand years
being over the horizon,
I can't see it.
12,000 years,
you might as well just be
speaking another language.
They don't understand.
My stupid brain can't wrap my
head around how long ago that is.
Terribly.
A little bit.
What would be left if you left
a car outside for 12,000 years,
you came back 12,000 years
later thing you'd find zero.
Nothing.
Absolutely nothing.
The earth would just reabsorb it.
Yeah.
What would be laughing and what
would be left would be the stones.
Yeah,
and that's what we're,
that's what we're left with.
I was just in tea when Arco in Bolivia,
and there are,
there are stone structures.
They're beautifully cut,
unbelievable precision
cutting of the stone.
They looked to me like they had
metal parts fitted into them.
At some point the metals gone,
the stone is left and where we're left
to wonder what was going on there.
So yeah,
the passage of time rubs out
all memory and all traces and,
and,
and it's very easy to get the
wrong idea about the past.
But places like Rebecca TAPI pieces like
good on padding in Indonesia are going
to change this.
What,
what year did people start using metal?
Um,
you know,
the ancient Egyptians,
you,
they,
they didn't make that,
but they,
they knew meteoritic ion.
The only form of iron that was available
to the ancient Egyptians was iron that
came in and meatier rights.
And there is the odd knife that's
been crafted from meteoritic iron,
but the metal that they used,
if you go back to 3000 or 2000,
800 BC was copper.
Um,
but they had a way of
hardening the copper,
uh,
some,
some loss technique of
making the copper harder.
That was,
that was definitely definitely present.
How do we know this is the
Orthodox view that I wrote because,
because the couple was used to
cut stone and copy your card.
Cut Stone with copper is way too soft
so they must have been some method of
making the copper harder.
This is,
this is the argument,
but that this is the orthodox view.
Um,
we don't really know.
You know,
what,
what they had and maybe metal
wasn't the only way to cut stone.
This is where I'd maybe
get a little bit mystical,
but maybe you know,
because our society has done things
a certain way that we use mechanical
advantage that we use machine tools that
we want to look for that in the past.
But maybe,
maybe there are all sorts of untapped
faculties of the human mind that the
ancients were working with in,
in one way or another.
Certainly when you go to a place like
one man in Peru outside of Cusco and you
see these gigantic
blocks of stone hundred,
hundred and 50 tons,
each fit it together like jigsaw puzzle,
the edges kind of
melting into one another.
The notion that some sort of heat
might've been used to shape these stones
begins to make a weird kind of sense,
some sort of heat heat here.
That's fascinating.
And there's vitrified stone up there.
I've in,
in my journey in Peru,
I spent,
I spent several days with a local
guy called hey Swisscom morrow,
who is now 77 years old.
And his father,
I'm afraid O'mara,
uh,
was working on that site back at the,
at the beginning of the 19 hundreds.
And,
and,
um,
they as a family have been studying
the megaliths of the Andes for,
for a hundred plus years now.
And they are actually
descended from the anchors.
So you would think if anybody had an
investment in saying that the ink has made
all this,
it would be them.
But they say no,
he's just Gomorrah is adamant.
The inkers have been wrongly handed
the majority of the architecture in the
Andes by archaeology.
The Incas only did a fraction of it and
most of what they did was pretty poor
quality.
The great stuff was done by earliest
civilizations and he took me and he showed
me vitrified stone,
which has been subjected
to fantastic heat and,
and melted and shines in a,
in a way that's um,
really stunning and striking
and convincing when you see it.
Uh,
that some kind of technology that is
not the technology that we use today was
being employed to put
these stones into place.
And archeologists have dismissed
such ideas for a very long time,
but I'm not sure how much longer they're
going to be able to dismiss them.
I don't know how they can dismiss those
enormous stones that have strange shapes
that are fitting like a
gigantic jigsaw puzzle.
It was like,
it was like giants a hundred feet tall,
decided to make a three
dimensional jigsaw puzzle.
Tell Jimmy what those images
would be to pull those up.
What would they be?
Um,
I maybe if I show you an image,
have him pull OkayWell Saksaywaman as a c,
s a y,
h.
U.
A M a n say,
and is also,
there's one stone that Giorgio sucralose
showed me where it was carved out of
this piece of stone.
There's this slab carved through the back
of it and removed and they don't have
no idea how they got
through this stone and Co.
Yeah,
they look at that image.
Oh my God.
That's me.
Which we'll pull it towards you.
This word,
this way.
No,
no,
no.
Just flatten.
Yeah,
there you go.
That's insane.
That's you standing next
to me standing next,
standing next to that stone and look at
the way those studs are fitted together.
You know,
I mean,
that is,
there's a really monstrous thing to do.
It's a jet,
just a gigantic work of art
that they've created and,
and it goes on for hundreds of feet.
This is not just this,
there's not just that section.
It goes on forever in these,
these huge walls and it does feel like
a three dimensional jigsaw puzzle.
And so beautiful too.
It means that the way they did it,
it's not,
they didn't make everything
square and know and level.
No,
they just decided to use this sort of
method of turning these stones into these
puzzle pieces and you go,
when you go look at it up close and you
realize that you can't get a sheet of
paper in the gaps between the joints,
you realize that you are looking at some
sort of technology that we don't get.
There's something they were there.
There was some way that these people were
able to do this and make it incredibly
difficult for themselves if
it was done in any modern way.
What's the mainstream
explanation for that?
Oh,
hours and hours of patient Labor by tens
of thousands of people grinding away at
the stones and making them all fit.
Consider the planning,
you know,
to make that happen.
Let me show the whole wall.
I've got the,
I've got a picture of the whole wall.
We could pull it up if you
just tell us what patient,
there's the whole world.
Oh my God.
When I say the whole wall,
I mean that's just a
section of the whole wall.
That wall runs for hundreds
of feet in all directions.
Um,
the planning that's involved in making
no single block of stone is the same size
as another.
They're all different sizes.
They're all tongue and grooved
into each other in this,
in this incredible way and it
really feels like they were melted.
They were kind of softened.
That's what his whiskey O'mara says.
He says these stores were softened by
some technique that we don't understand.
He thinks he'd was involved,
they were softened and in a soft state
they were fitted together and then they
solidified.
Is that possible that they figured
out some way to make a blow torch or
something,
but I think it's possible.
But even then,
how do you push them into place?
Not a blow torch necessarily,
but so this is something goes on the
defies explanation there and what's there
and I don't think we need
aliens to explain it.
I think it's human work.
I think it's human workmanship,
but it's at a level and at a standard
that we do not fully understand.
Yeah.
The,
um,
that,
that alien thing gets real weird,
you know?
Well,
it's like,
you know,
I have been,
I've had the privilege of traveling
around this planet for the last 25 years,
looking at ancient sites.
Look at that.
Amazing that sex.
Say Walmart.
How big are the largest stones?
Uh,
we're about 20 feet high.
150 to 200 tons in weight.
Uh,
six to eight feet thick.
just,
just monstrous.
200 tons is 400,000 pounds?
Is that what it is?
200 tons.
I think of it in kilos.
A ton is a ton.
Is a thousand kilograms.
So,
oh,
you're kilo man killing man.
I don't,
I don't do it in pounds anymore.
Police.
You don't do it in stone.
Now we go to England,
UFC Wayans we have to say like 10 stone.
Everything.
There were 14 pounds in a stone.
Okay,
so 10 stone made your 140 pounds.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's really complicated.
Yeah.
They're sexy woman.
Now the point looking up at the
top left of the screen there,
there's some inferior work on top of
the better work and what [inaudible] is
saying and the inferior work
was the work of the anchors,
but the other stuff is much older.
So the smaller rocks that
were easily manipulated,
now they were copying the oldest style
and respecting it and overbuilding and
building around it,
but,
but they were honoring an earlier and
earlier work of construction and the
conventional dating of
this is very recent.
The anchors,
the anchors were wiped out by the Spanish.
Uh,
15,
30,
40.
They were destroyed as an empire.
They don't,
he existed according to history
for 150 years before that,
200 years before that at the
outside and all of this work,
this incredible megalithic work
that's all over the Andes mountains.
You can't,
you can't move for bumping into it.
All of it is supposed to have been built
in that 200 year period by the Incas
because archaeology can't just can't bear
the idea that there might've been some
earlier culture.
Why date it then?
It seems like if it's so
confusing and so there,
there's so many open ended questions
where when you see these enormous pieces,
when we see them fitted together,
when you don't have an
explanation for how they did it,
you're not exactly sure who did it
because the history gets really murky when
you get that far back.
You know why date it?
I agree why data,
I don't,
I don't understand why
they have to do that.
Well,
it seems to me that archeology comes
to history with a preexisting reference
frame and makes everything fit into it,
makes everything fit into it and that's
been the mistake of science down the
ages.
There was a long period that very good
example of this is is that the notion
that the notion that the sun revolved
around the earth that was based on a
preexisting reference
seemed to make sense.
Get up in the morning,
look at the sonic rises,
goes through the sky,
but it was complete nonsense.
It's the earth that's
going around the sun.
You have to change the reference frame
in order to see what's really going on.
And I think that's the problem
with history and archeology.
What impact,
if any,
has this go back?
Lee TAPI discovered,
go back,
Lee Tempe,
discovery changed archeologists view of,
of,
of back dating things.
As I mentioned,
I liked clash Schmidt when I met him,
the archeologist who is
working on Quebec City,
Tempe.
Um,
I thought he was,
I thought he was charming and
enthusiastic and I enjoyed his energy.
But when I asked him about when I said,
um,
so what does it feel like to be
the man who discovered the site?
There's rewriting history and he said,
no,
it's not rewriting history.
It's adding a new chapter
to existing history.
He still wants to fit it into that
reference frame somehow that we have to,
okay,
we have to completely rethink our
ideas about the upper paleolithic,
but somehow desperately we must look at
this site in a way that's not going to
rock the boat too much.
And I was sad to hear that.
I think,
I think especially when,
when he himself admits that at least 20
times as much if not 50 times as much,
it's still under the ground
or waiting to be excavated.
Um,
I think a little bit of
provisional thinking is needed
before you just attribute
that to him being a professional academic.
Yes.
I think the professional
professional academia,
particularly in the realm of archeology
encourages those who are working in the
field to think in terms
of the existing paradigm,
not to think in terms of challenging
the paradigm because it's dangerous.
If you challenge the paradigm,
uh,
you,
you're going to be ridiculed
by your colleagues and,
and regarded as completely lunatic and,
and,
and attacked and insulted.
Uh,
so it's better not to
challenge that paradigm,
but what a fascinating area of
research to not challenge the paradigm,
an area where you have so little
information about what could have possibly
happened when you get
back to 5,000 years ago,
6,000 years ago,
7,000 years ago,
and you're trying to piece these puzzles
again to pretend that you have the
entire timeline.
It seems a little silly.
It's pretty crazy.
It seems so,
I mean,
it's one thing if you're trying to pretend
that you have a timeline when you're
dealing with something,
or excuse me,
to pretend you have all the information.
When you're dealing with something like
mathematics or when you're dealing with
something like very clear,
uh,
manuscripts,
you know like,
oh,
we have a,
you know,
the Dead Sea scrolls very clearly,
x amount of years old.
This is the thing with history where
you have written documents that you can
draw upon where you have
those written documents.
You can be reasonably certain
about what's going on.
The further back we go,
we don't have the written
documents beyond 5,000 years.
We have no written documents and to draw
a fixed and firm conclusions about what
happened before 5,000 years ago on the
basis of a few things dug out of the
ground.
It's not good enough.
It's,
it's,
it's a mistake that's being made
and that I believe is going to,
is going
to change.
It's got to be painful.
It's going to be slow.
It was painful to change the Ptolemaic
system to the COPERNICAN system,
but it will happen.
The system will change.
And the,
the,
the backdating of the Sphinx,
has there been any progress on that now
because of go back Lee tamping because
the what,
what Robert Schoch did
in exposing the erosion,
the water erosion,
and we briefly touched on this before,
but I've seen people
dispute it and boy itself,
it seems so forced and labored there.
They're disputing the,
I have no doubt that
rubber shock is right.
Robert Robert Shotgun
and John Anthony West,
they're right about the sphinx.
And they have been attacked
in all kinds of ways,
in all kinds of elaborate,
contorted explanations have been given
to explain away that kind of weathering.
But the fact is they remained to be right.
And now we have the tappy.
Now on the other side of the world,
we have Gunung Padang,
we have sites that are 12,000
plus years old indisputably.
So I think it sooner or later will
cause a reconsideration of the Sphinx.
I hope so.
And that's something that I,
I also intend to focus on.
Well,
I think it has to.
And as soon as John Jamie
gets back from the bathroom,
we'll show some of the images of the,
the,
the Sphinx in closure
then led Robert Schoch,
who is a geologist to very
clearly proclaimed that
what you're dealing with is
thousands of years of water erodes
just as if he has a wheelchair.
The smoothness of it,
the curves,
the fact that there's all these fissures
that indicate water running down.
Yeah.
And then the area,
I honestly think shock Rabbids Shulkin
John West are going to be seen in future
generations as the Copernicus of their
time that they saw what nobody else saw.
And,
and they had the courage to put,
to put the information out there and,
and they were attacked for it.
And you know,
people don't get bent at
the stake these days for,
for proposing alternative ideas.
But in a kind of way,
you know,
we do,
there's the,
the,
the vicious nature of the attacks on
people who propose an alternative view of
history.
But I think in,
in our lifetimes,
we will see this change.
And if folks haven't seen,
um,
or haven't heard me talk about John
Anthony West amazing documentary series on
Egypt,
it's called magical Egypt and
I can't recommend it enough.
It is absolutely fascinating.
So in depth,
I believe,
is it six or seven DVDs?
I don't know how many,
like that big,
big collection of DVDs.
It's a massive,
massive amount of work.
And John is a man who's devoted
his whole life to understanding an,
uh,
an alternative understanding of Egypt
done with great wisdom and great care.
Yeah,
it's a really,
really incredible series
that I've watched many,
many times over and over again and
try to absorb as much of it as I,
as I can.
But it's,
it's so staggering.
And he also showed very clear that there's
some different styles of techniques
of,
of building and that these older
techniques that you find or different
techniques or all on a
lower level of the soil,
it's exactly,
it's exactly like
it is in the Peruvian Andes and,
and,
uh,
Bolivia.
Um,
that what,
what has happened I think
is that archeology has
taken the work of the latest
culture to work on the site and
handed the whole site over to,
it actually gives us a
very complicated site.
You have the Subterranean Chamber
beneath the great pyramid.
Why do we have to believe that that is
from the same date as the pyramid itself?
Uh,
you have the,
the so called mortuary
temples and valley temples,
these gigantic megalithic structures.
The Valley Temple beside the Sphinx is
actually made of blocks of limestone that
were cut out from around the Sphinx
to create the body of the Sphinx.
So if the Sphinx is 12,000 years old,
and I honestly think it is,
then the valley temples are
12,000 years old as well.
Um,
the,
what we have are very complex multilayered
sites where there's a very ancient
megalithic layer of architecture and
the later culture comes along perhaps
venerates that perhaps
overbuilds around it,
um,
and attempts to copy it in some ways.
And the mistake has been both in the
Andes and in Egypt that the later culture
has been attributed with all the work.
We need a more sophisticated,
the more in depth exploration of this
and I think correctly Tempe is going to
force us to do that.
If Jamie,
if you could pull up some of the
images that Robert Schoch uh,
created of the water
errosion as opposed to,
I mean,
you showed it a little animated,
uh,
or illustrated image of it before,
but it's pretty fascinating stuff and
that seems to me to be the ones smoking
gun in Egypt,
that sort of points.
It's a smoking gun for sure.
It's a smoking gun,
which the mainstream academia
has tried to ignore the smoke,
but if the smoke is there and,
and um,
go back to Tappi going padding,
other sites are going to
force them to reconsider that.
What are they going to do if they dig
up something that's 30,000 years old?
I mean,
well,
I hope that they're not going
to hide it and pretend it works.
Well,
I know of cases where it's happened.
I know it happened in Malta
when what happened in Malta,
in the hyper igm,
which is an underground structure
in mortar of amazing undergrads,
one of the one plate,
this should be on everybody's bucket list.
By the way,
the hyper GM in multimedia
is an incredible place.
It's like,
it's like a huge temple
complex cutout underground.
Uh,
and,
and um,
there are traces of red
ochre paint on the walls.
They look much more like the caves,
the painted caves than they look
like stuff from the Neolithic.
And there was at one time,
uh,
a figure of a hybrid creature,
a half bison,
half bull.
Um,
such a figure would be normal in the
painted caves from 30,000 years ago,
but doesn't fit in with the idea that
the hyper g and belongs to 5,000 years
ago.
And,
uh,
this was solved by a certain
gentleman who shall remain nameless,
who had the bison bull scrubbed off
the walls of the hyper geome in Malta.
It was literally scrubbed off.
I reported this at some length in my book.
Underworld.
Well,
who do,
who do they think scrubbed it?
Well,
we know who scrubbed it.
Um,
it was the former director of museums
and in Malta.
Yeah,
back in back in the 60s.
He scrubbed it off the
walls and when I took the,
I took the,
the national museums
of multitask over this,
when I was back there making a
documentary with channel four,
we put in a formal document to them
asking them to answer this charge and they
refuse to answer it.
They would not comment upon it at all.
Wow.
So yeah,
I mean archeologists do actually sometimes
do incredibly dishonest things to
maintain the view of history.
That's so sad.
I mean,
it just think about the whole cycle of
thinking that goes from being a young
person wanting to explore history,
wanting to become an archeologist,
getting involved in archeology,
getting involved in academia and then
destroying evidence that's contrary to
what you've been taught or are teaching.
It's the opposite of science,
pure science.
It's so scary that human nature and even
in a scientific work sometimes finds
its way to rear its ugly head that the,
the nasty aspects of human nature can
even find their way into archeology.
Most unfortunate,
yeah.
That they can't in certain
sciences because it's so
cut and dry mathematics and
physics and you know,
but in,
in archeology,
so much is based on interpretation and
the interpretation of very limited facts
actually.
So what's next for you?
What do you do from here?
Well,
I am writing at,
at the moment I'm researching and writing
a sequel to fingerprints of the gods,
fingerprints as that goes,
it was published in 1995.
Um,
the reason I'm doing a sequel
is because of the new evidence.
We've talked about Gunung
Padang in Indonesia,
we've talked about back Lee tappy,
we've talked about the comment.
The comment for me is the cataclysmic
smoking gun that explains how we lost a
whole civilization and a whole
lot of material like this.
I'm not going to write an update
to fingerprints of the gods.
I'm going to write a completely
new book and that book,
I'm in the process of researching.
That's why I'm on these
travels at the moment.
That's where I'm going to Indonesia
at the beginning of December.
Uh,
that book will be published at the end,
uh,
in the fall of 2015 I'm due to deliver
it to the publishers in December,
2014 and it'll be published
in the fall of 2015.
And,
and this,
I see this as,
um,
in a way,
a kind of summation of my life's
work on this whole issue of a lost
civilization.
And I feel very committed to doing it.
But honestly,
my heart these days is in writing novels.
Really.
I love writing novels.
Yeah.
So it took a long time for
you to break away from,
you were originally a journalist then
went from journalism to writing about the
ancient history and an alternative
view of ancient history,
but it was a,
it was a psychedelic experience
that led you to want to write.
It was a psychedelic experience with
Iowasca back in 2007 that set me on the
track to write my first novel,
which is,
which is entangled,
uh,
which is a story of two young women,
one living 24,000 years ago in the Stone
Age one living in modern Los Angeles,
who,
whose destinies are entangled.
The time is not what it seems,
that it's a kind of spiral,
a cat's cradle
of into crossing lines
rather than an arrow.
And they are brought together by a benign
supernatural force who I call the blue
angel to do battle with a
demon who travels through time.
And then since then I've written war God,
which is a,
which is a novel about the
Spanish conquest of Mexico,
um,
did get a British publisher for that
book that book's being published in,
in,
in Britain.
And it did okay.
It did well enough at any rate for the
publishers in Britain to commission
volumes two and three because it's a,
because it's a series,
I couldn't get any American
publisher to take that book on.
But,
uh,
because publishing sees people in
terms of brands and I am branded as a
nonfiction author and how dare
I write fiction as I dare you.
How dare I do that.
Um,
you know,
life is short.
I wanted,
I want to try many,
many things and uh,
so what I've done is a published it a
pretty much effectively self published it
in America through Amazon and the
book is available on amazon.com.
That's what it looks like by the way,
the u s edition people
can also order uniforms.
People can also order it from bookshops
but it's easier to get it from
amazon.com.
What is that?
The undercover?
Well that's actually
derived from an Aztec image,
um,
of a,
of a skull,
um,
found on a,
a ball court cause they played this,
this terrible game of ball game
where the loser had his head cut off.
Um,
and,
and a war God is,
is the story of the
Spanish conquest of Mexico.
And I,
if I could say to anybody who's listening
special offer for the next 10 days
only,
go to my website,
which is Graham hancock.com and click on
the war section and you will find links
to get it on amazon.com either
as an ebook or as a printed book.
Uh,
and what I will do is write to me at
the address that's on my website there,
which is,
which is war God
dedications@gmail.com write to me,
I will write back to you and I will send
you a signed dedicated bookplate that's
essentially a label you buy the
book from Amazon in the normal way,
but you will receive through the post
from me if you write to me and give me
your postal address,
you will receive through the post from me,
uh,
assigned dedicated bookplate
to place inside it.
Wow,
that's awesome.
But that's 10 days that,
that uh,
that that offer is available
cause a beautiful interstate war.
God dedication's there were guard
dedications@gmail.com that's a beautiful
image.
That image of the Aztec skull.
He had read something
somewhere where scholars were,
they were contemplating whether or
not they were incorrect about the,
the sacrifice.
And they were saying that there,
there may be a possibility that they
played a game where they sacrificed the
winning team.
Uh,
human sacrifice was conducted
on an industrial scale.
If it has take empire.
I,
I've investigated this very,
very thoroughly.
This novel is a novel.
It's a work of,
it's a work of fiction,
but I've thoroughly grounded
it in the historical facts.
And it ended,
this was a tough history to investigate.
Uh,
I mean the,
the Aztecs were truly
a terrifying culture.
Uh,
the Spanish who turned up with 490 men
in 11 ships on the Gulf of Mexico in 15,
19 where if anything and
even more terrifying culture,
uh,
these,
these are two martial cultures
who are brought together in this,
in this horrendous conflict.
Um,
but you've,
you know,
it's,
it was a different time.
It was a different world then in,
in 15,
19.
And,
and,
uh,
I've tried to tell the story through
the eyes of ordinary human beings.
My main heroin is a
true historical figure.
A woman called Molly [inaudible] who
became the mistress and the interpreter of
Cortez.
And when she enters history,
she's given to Cortez as a,
as a surrender gift by the Maya.
When she enters history,
it's already clear that she
has a grudge against Moctezuma,
the Aztec Emperor,
and that she is going to use Cortez
as her instrument to bring him down.
And I was just interested in her quest
for revenge against the Aztec Empire and
also to have,
uh,
a woman who was a hero in a
story rather than just a man.
What is,
what is the,
trying to think through
the first little bit.
Yeah.
What is the origin of this
horrific level of human sacrifice?
Like what,
what started it all with the Aztecs?
Like why?
Well,
that's again,
that's a reason why I've written war
God as a novel because for the Aztecs,
they believe that they were in touch with
a supernatural entity that they called
Witsell,
a poshly hummingbird.
I use his name in the English
translation in the book Hummingbird,
who is their god of war?
He's there.
He's there war guard.
And,
and this is an area where we have to
recognize that there is a dark side to
psychedelics.
I am a big fan of psychedelics and I do
think that psychedelics have a hugely
important role to play.
But the Aztecs were using
psilocybin mushrooms in their
human sacrifice rituals.
And Moctezuma was encountering
this demonic entity Hummingbird,
uh,
in Psilocybin trances and,
and was constantly being
given incredibly bad,
even wicked advice by him.
And there's this,
so I'm,
I'm playing with the idea
of dark spiritual forces at
work behind human history,
manipulating Moctezuma,
manipulating Cortez and plunging
mankind into this sea of,
of cruelty in and misery.
Um,
and you know,
what redeems the story for
me and does it at all times,
is that the human spirit's
still shines through.
Even in the darkest times.
There is courage,
there is decency,
there is love people.
People struggle to show
the best in themselves and,
and,
and to deliver the best in themselves.
So I've tried to show both sides of this.
This book is about the
battle of good against evil.
And it's not that the Spanish are good
and the Aztecs evil because the Spanish
were wicked,
wicked,
wicked as well.
Um,
and they did terrible things.
They fed people to dogs.
Um,
they,
they burned people at the state.
What is actually burning
somebody at the stake,
if not a form of human sacrifice.
That's what the Spanish
were due to their God.
They were sacrificing
people to their gods.
So no different from the
Aztecs and that respect,
the level of sacrifice.
So insane that I,
I tried to explain it to a friend of
mine and he literally told me I was
bullshitting when I told them,
uh,
that 80,000 people were sacrificing.
Thousand were sacrificed
period of like four days,
four days,
uh,
with teams of killers,
50 teams of killers working at the top
of the great pyramid to process people
within a minute or two per process.
Them,
I think of it,
that's how it's done.
It was an done on an industrial scale.
Cues of victims stretching
a mile in every direction,
uh,
marching up the pyramid and having there
and having their hearts cutout and all
of this in honor of a,
of a demonic,
uh,
demonic entity,
which the Aztecs passionately believed in.
They believed that he needed to
be fed human hearts and blood.
And when they call,
they called him Witsell a poshly,
which means hummingbird at
the left hand of the son.
He's the war God after whom,
this after whom this novel is a is,
is,
is named.
Uh,
and he,
I,
the way,
the way I look at it,
the same demonic entity is
manipulating both Moctezuma and Cortez.
He appears to Cortez in dreams and
takes on the disguise of Saint Peter.
He appears to Moctezuma as the,
as the war garb,
but it's the same demon
that's playing with men.
And that's one reason why
I wrote this as a novel,
because you can't get into this
stuff in a nonfiction book,
but it's very real.
It's a very real part of human history
and the whole shape of the world we live
in today.
The,
the terrible genocide that
happened in North America,
the destruction of North American Indians,
the conquest of Peru,
the whole relationship of
the European powers to,
to Africa for example.
All of this was based on what
happened in those years between 15,
19 and 15,
21 when the Spanish conquest
of Mexico and folded.
Um,
and,
and uh,
I think we would let on to a dark track.
Imagine how it could have
been if those two cultures,
if the Spanish and the Aztecs had
met one another in a spirit of mutual
learning,
how much there was to exchange,
how much each side of the Atlantic could
have learned from the other instead of
three.
It becomes this kind of conflagration of,
uh,
of,
of blood,
but it's difficult to place ourselves in
the mindset of the people of that time.
It is difficult for us to do that today.
Um,
and I have to say,
when you look at the Spaniards,
I mean 490 men turn up on the coast of
Mexico in 11 ships and they are going to
take on this empire that can put
200,000 men into the field that will,
if they catch you,
will match you up the pyramid
and cut your heart out.
And many Spaniards were
sacrificed in sight of their,
of their colleagues.
Um,
it was an extraordinary time.
It was an extraordinary event and men
of those times were different from,
from men of today,
I believe.
What is the mainstream
explanation for human sacrifice?
Like what,
what do they believe started off?
Well,
that it's,
that it's a feeding of psychic
energy to supernatural beings.
That's what human sacrifices about that,
that that you take the psychic energy
of the individual you're going to kill
you,
kill them,
take their psychic energy and feed it
to these vampire like creatures that are
lying in the beyond that,
that thrive on human misery and pain.
And you know,
who are we to say that
such things do not exist?
We don't understand the nature of reality.
And if you look at human culture day,
I mean look at wars,
look at wars that are
happening in the world today.
Look at the tens of thousands of people
that are being slaughtered in warfare
today.
That's also a kind of human sacrifice.
I think we have to consider
the possibility that some
kind of demonic force is
thriving on this and,
and,
and being nourished by it.
And that's one of the things that we
need to do as human beings is to separate
ourselves from that and say,
no,
we will not do that.
We will not feed that energy.
We will not offer lives easier.
The beyond.
I don't go with you on that,
but I do in a way,
I don't believe in demons,
but I do.
I think it's undeniable that there have
been massive groups of people that have
participated in horrific things.
So what is that,
if not demonic?
I believe it's,
I believe it's demonic.
I can't prove it.
I can't prove that that's the case.
I just think we should stay open to that
possibility that the nature of reality
is so complex and so multilayered that
there may be much more going on than we
think.
And that if we just,
if we just confine our explanations of
things to purely economic and material
terms,
we may be missing part of the picture.
Uh,
and that when the ancient spoke
of angels and demons to use words,
I'm not saying that I believe
in angels or demons as such,
but when they spoke of
Lawton light and dark forces,
negative and positive
forces playing on the,
on the human race,
maybe they had something going.
Maybe there was something to that.
Well,
I always consider the fact that human
beings have this incredibly broad spectrum
of possibility.
It's incredibly bar,
broad spectrum of
behavior and personality,
of circumstance,
of genetics,
and that there's this
Yin and Yang of life.
There's this pull and push of life,
and that the extreme ends
of it are good and evil,
good and evil.
Yeah.
And,
and it's,
it may not be a demon,
but it might as well be a
demon if you're marching.
80,000 people off the side of a pyramid
and cutting their heart out with a
fucking stone tool.
Yeah.
That's demonic.
It might as well be,
might as well be a demon.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and that is a,
that is worth considering.
And the A,
and the question is,
what is,
you know,
what is going on here?
I have a very dear friend called James
Tiburon who refers to this world that we
live in as a university of
[inaudible] that we have,
um,
that we have lessons
to learn from duality,
maybe dualities,
not the whole thing.
Maybe there is an overarching
unity and oneness in,
in all things.
But right now here in this
incarnation on planet earth,
we have to learn from duality.
And the thing about duality
is human beings can choose.
We can always choose,
even in the most straightened
and difficult circumstances,
we can always choose for the
light rather than the darkness.
We can always choose for
good rather than evil.
We don't have to take that act that
causes pain and suffering to another human
being.
We never have to do that.
We can always choose not to.
The alarming thing is that people often
will choose the act that causes pain and
suffering to others and we are defined
by our choices and this is where we need
to grow up as a species
and start to choose,
start to choose the light.
Do you think that this broad
spectrum of possibilities,
whether it's possibilities
of thinking or behavior,
it's almost there to educate us as to
the possibilities of this destructive
possibilities that this huge spectrum
that we have is is it's so open ended and
so massive as to indicate that there
are these extreme variables and these
extreme variables can push
us by understanding of the
consequences into a more
positive way.
They didn't exist.
If these horrific ideas of war and
of human sacrifice didn't exist,
maybe we wouldn't appreciate love as much.
We would not appreciate love as much
and we would have nothing to learn from
this,
this strange and troublesome
and mysterious and beautiful
thing called being a
human being.
We have to learn here.
We learn here because there are those,
those two different poles at the extreme
end of which are good and evil with all
kinds of gradations in between.
That is what teaches us and then it's
the choices we make day by day as we go
through life that define us ultimately.
Now,
whether there is any
transcendental consequence to that,
something beyond this life,
something that some,
some,
some reckoning to take place as,
as the ancient Egyptians
certainly believe there was.
I don't know for sure but I,
but I do know that a lifetime of making
decisions that cause pain and suffering
to others and that inflict and,
and that detract from their sovereignty,
uh,
is,
is a life that ultimately the person
who's lived that life is diminished by it.
I want to know how they got
80,000 people to get an aligned,
to give their heart to cut out terror.
Total terror.
They were the dominant military force in,
in the Valley of Mexico at
that they were very dominant.
They asked,
tex had a huge secret police force.
They spied on one another.
They spied on their neighbors.
They would carry out human sacrifices
as object lessons to their neighbors.
You will pay us tribute or
this is what we will do to you.
They skinned people alive.
They would,
they would truly,
truly awful.
Uh,
and,
and it was their awfulness.
It was the horrific nature of as tech
behavior that led them to lose that battle
against Cortez,
uh,
because,
because quarter had numbers are crazy.
Cortez,
490 men as TX 200,000 is pretty,
you think it's pretty
obvious who's going to win?
How does Cortez,
when he wins,
because the Aztecs
neighbors hate the Aztecs.
They have lived in terror
of them for 200 years,
and they see him as a liberator.
They see him as somebody who is going to
lift this yoke off their shoulders and,
and allow them to be free.
Of course,
they didn't know that.
He was just gonna make things worse.
Uh,
but,
uh,
in the time,
in the nature of things,
at the time,
that was how it was felt.
I mean,
it's a fact that there were 30
million people in Mexico in 15,
19 and 50 years later,
they were just 1 million.
The Spanish were responsible for
a genocide of 29 million people.
So they didn't make things better,
but it looked like they'd
make things better.
And they came as a kind of comma.
And,
and here's the weird thing again,
I'll show this cover because
beside it is the feathered serpent,
um,
in this,
uh,
photograph,
and that's quite solid collateral.
The,
the feathered serpent who is,
who is there.
And this is another reason why Cortez one,
uh,
because he was able to play
on the prophecy that a god
of peace would return and
that,
that God would overthrow wicked king.
And he was the feathered serpent.
He was quite psychiatry and
it was predicted that he
would return in the Aztec
year one reed.
And it so happened that Cortez landed on
the coast of Mexico with his tiny army
in the Aztec year one reed 15,
19 was the year one reed.
So the return of [inaudible] was
a key part of Cortez is a victory.
And my heroin.
Molly Nol is the person who
tells Cortez about this.
She,
she's the one who shows him how to
exploit this and how to play Moctezuma's
superstition and fear to
represent himself as this God,
but of course,
Cortez is not a god of peace.
He's a,
he's a god of war.
It's a quite a quite a coincidence.
It was amazing.
Amazing coincidence.
Is that what it is or is it a prophecy?
Again,
you have to wonder.
You have to wonder how this,
how this could have happened because
the prophecy was quite specific.
That quits our collateral
and his companions would
return in the year one reed,
they would return in ships that
moved by themselves without paddles.
What were the Spanish
ships with their sales,
but ships that move by
themselves without paddles.
They would be dressed in shining metal
armor and they would deploy weapons
called she who cattle,
which means fire serpents,
which would dismember man at a distance,
I.
E.
Guns,
all of this cannon,
all of this was right
there in the prophecy.
And Cortez was able to
step right into that,
into that role and to turn around what
should have been an obvious defeat for
his tiny force into,
into a stunning,
stunning victory.
That is absolutely fascinating.
So many correlating ideas.
Yeah.
So many correlating ideas come together.
And that's why I felt I want to write a
book about this and that's why I thought
I wanted to get inside the heads of the
characters and deal with that battle of
good against evil at a,
at a level that won't,
can't do in a nonfiction book.
How old was this prophesy?
Well,
that image that I showed of the,
of the feathered serpent,
um,
again,
I show it that image of
the feathered serpent,
which side of my screen and my own here,
that image of the feathered serpent is,
I'm from La Venta in the Gulf of Mexico.
And that is in the oldest
archeological strata of Mexico.
That image dates to an archeological
strata that is about 1,500 BC,
uh,
3000,
500 years ago.
The stone itself may be
much older than that,
but the strategist dug up from
was already 3,500 years old.
So this notion,
and there are many images of,
of people with kind of Caucasian features
found in the same stratum notion of a
mysterious strangers who were in Mexico
at some time and who would return is
very ancient in the Mexican system.
Wow.
And how did they,
I mean there's a,
there's a very different
language that they used then,
then hours.
And it was very difficult for
them to decipher a lot of the,
uh,
especially the Mayan
there were in the Aztec,
the way their,
uh,
what,
what exactly they were saying.
How did they figure out that the,
they're saying ships
without oars and things.
It's fired guns the whole day.
It's an interesting point that you raise.
So when Cortez fest lands in Mexico,
he lands in the Yucatan,
uh,
and the people who live in
the Yucatan are the Maya.
They're not the Aztecs.
They are the first people he encounters.
And there he has an
incredible stroke of luck.
He can't speak a word of mine.
And nor can anybody else
in his group of Spaniards.
But they discovered that somebody who
looks like them is living on the mainland
as a prisoner of the Maya.
They're Spanish first landed in
Cozumel holiday resort today,
and the the,
the Mayan tribe on Cozumel
were relatively peaceful,
but the people on the mainland were not.
And they,
the,
the Maya have Cozumel came to Cortez
and they said this with sign language.
They pointed at him and they said
Castilian they actually told him he was a
Castilian and caught his thought.
How can they know I'm a Castilian?
That's what the Spanish called themselves.
And,
and gradually through sign language,
he figured out what it was,
that there was a Spaniard who'd been
shipwrecked on the coast of Mexico.
At some point,
it turned out it was 11 years before.
In fact,
26 Spaniards had been shipwrecked 11
years before 25 of them had been eaten by
the Maya,
but one Hiroshima Aguilar had survived.
So Cortez grabbed him and I
tell this story in my book,
and Cortez became a Aguilar,
became Cortez is first interpreter.
So suddenly,
because he spoke fluent Maya.
By then,
he'd been living amongst the Maya for
11 years and he spoke Spanish as well.
So suddenly they could
understand the Maya,
they could communicate with the Maya,
but then when they went on and they
encountered the Aztecs for the first time,
the Aztec spoke another language
and that language was not a wattle.
The language of the Aztecs and ag
will are suddenly became useless.
He couldn't speak Nahuatl
and that's where my heroine,
who is a true historical figure,
Malina thrusts herself forward.
She's already been handed
over to Cortez as a prisoner.
She speaks fluent Navajo,
Atul and fluent Maya,
and she communicates to Cortez,
look,
I can work with your man,
Aguilar.
I will give you,
you will put the words from Spanish,
you'll speak Spanish.
Aguilar will give me those words in
Maya and I will translate them into now
Hawaii and the reverse
with the Aztec and pastors.
And within weeks she
has replaced Anguillara.
She's a genius.
She mastered Spanish.
She becomes Cortez sole interpreter and
she's communicating for him with the
Aztecs.
And there's an amazing scene where
she encounters Moctezuma directly,
she and Cortez face to
face with Moctezuma.
And in those days if you
looked Moctezuma in the eye,
you were killed.
This is what the Aztecs,
nobody could look them in the eye.
They had to fall on their faces and the
local accounts from the time tell us how
Marinell standing there on the causeway
outside Tenochtitlan looked Moctezuma
straight in the eye.
She never lowered her eyes for a second
as she gave him the words of Cortez.
And I'm just fascinated by
the courage of this woman and,
and what drove her to use Cortez,
her instrument to bring Moctezuma down.
And she's a real historic,
real historical figure.
There's still a statue of
here in Mexico City today.
She became not only
Cortez is a interpreter,
but also his mistress and um,
the mother and the mother of his child.
Yeah.
And by all accounts,
she was a very beautiful woman.
I'd would be disappointed
if you didn't banger.
You can't find a single cell bad angle
as tech painting of Cortez that doesn't
have [inaudible] in it.
And she was in the heart of every battle.
Uh,
and there's another
Spanish writer of the time,
um,
uh,
who,
who spoke about her as a bee Bernardy
as a common soldier who wrote a memoir
called the history of the
conquest of new Spain.
And it's He who,
who tells us that Martinelle's beauty,
her grace,
her courage,
her,
her charm.
She's regarded as a
traitor in Mexico today.
Cause she,
Cortez said it,
he said,
aside from God himself,
it was Marlina who gave me
this conquest of Mexico.
Uh,
and,
and that's it.
One woman changed the
history of the world.
Uh,
Lamar Lynch.
That's how the Spanish knew her.
They knew her as Lama lynching.
Wow,
that's amazing.
So she's the central
character in my novel,
and we'd meet her in the fattening
pen at the foot of the great pyramid,
along with another woman who
plays a big part in my story,
a young,
which called Toci.
And this is the motive.
This is why Marla,
Marla escapes.
But this is why she wants to bring
Moctezuma down because she sees him as the
head of an empire of terror.
And she sees Cortez as the only way
to bring Moctezuma to his knees.
Well,
it's fascinated.
They would regard her as a traitor.
When you think about what Montezuma
had done to his own people.
That's,
that's amazing.
Well,
again,
to give balance,
we have to say that the
Spanish did in horrible,
horrible things.
Feeding people to dogs,
using people as target
practice for their weapons.
Let's see if this Spanish Toledo steel,
we'll cut off this man's arm.
You know,
things,
things like that.
They just,
they,
they were,
they were true,
true,
true horrors.
And,
and Cortez was a man of war
in every possible way and
an a machiavellian player.
Very cunning,
very clever.
Um,
you can't help admiring
him in certain ways,
but,
but he was unbelievably cruel.
What brought down Cortez Cortez
was brought down by old age.
He,
he,
uh,
wanted to become the king of Mexico
after he eventually apocalyptic final
battle.
When the Spanish took tell us did land,
which is the old name for make to Mexico
City and Cortez really it's clear that
his plan was to become
the new king of Mexico,
but the king of Spain had different
ideas and they pulled Cortez down.
They
gave him,
they gave him a title,
he became a Marquess.
But uh,
he was never allowed
to fulfill his dreams.
And I see Karma at work in that as well.
Um,
if he'd been a better man,
perhaps he would have been
allowed to fulfill some dreams,
whatever.
The guy lived to be old.
It's amazing for those times and
those times you live to be 60,
you were old.
How old did he live?
He lived to be about 58.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
No antibiotics,
no asprin.
No.
And they had a massive war.
Wounds.
He was,
he was clubbed on the head.
His skull was broken.
They've,
they've examined the skull of Cortez and
there's three separate times that his
skull was fractured.
What battles and a,
in each time he recovered and,
and bounced back.
They were men of steel.
The Spaniards.
They were,
they were the ultimate warriors.
We have a tiny though they were small,
but they were mean like how
big were they in five feet,
five feet tall?
They were small guys.
Was that because of a lack of
food and I guess a Trisha I guess.
I guess so.
It's a,
it's a nutritional issue.
They're all,
you know,
people are tolerate today in
those times they were small.
That is absolutely fascinating,
isn't it?
How much does stitch the shape
of human beings has changed?
Take Japan,
the shape of human beings has changed
radically in Japan in the last,
in the last 50 years,
there's some enormous Japanese,
Japanese,
no big giant wrestlers.
Exactly.
There's been quite a few that have
entered into mixed martial arts,
which just enormous,
enormous men and it's to
do is to do with nutrition.
Definitely.
Definitely fascinating.
So can I say that again?
If anybody is interested in actually
supporting my work and spending a few
dollars on getting hold of a copy of war,
God,
go to my website,
buy it through the Amazon link,
check out the email address that's there,
which is war God dedications@gmail.com
write to me and I will at my own expense
by air mail send you assigned dedicated
bookplate to go inside your copy of Walk
God.
But that offer is only good
for about the next 10 days.
I guarantee you just saw the gang of
books cause that was really fascinating.
I'm,
I'm going to buy it tonight.
I'm really blown away by that whole idea.
The whole story.
The woman who was the
translator as a whole thing.
It's so fascinating that there's,
when you live in this sweet,
cushy society that we live in today,
especially here in Los Angeles where
it doesn't even rain and you know,
go to a supermarket and get some meat
is everything's so soft and easy.
Everything's laid on hard for us to
wrap our heads around that just 500 plus
years ago,
this was going down in Mexico.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Graham Hancock.
Every time you come on,
it's better than the time
before you blew me away again,
man.
You,
you,
you broke whatever you'd,
whatever record you sat in the
last one as each other today.
Man,
I hope a million people go out
and buy your book after that.
That's absolutely fascinating.
So again,
it's war God.
You can get it on Amazon.
And the book that really got me into
Graham Hancock in the first place,
which has fingerprints of the gods.
Also available everywhere on
Amazon tangle links for war.
Got Her on my website,
Graham hancock.com very clearly marked.
Beautiful.
Thank you very much man.
That was amazing.
Really,
really fascinating stuff.
And uh,
our sponsors
thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to audible.com go to audible.com
forward slash Joe and get yourself a
free audio book and thanks
also to try to find the link.
There it is.
Thanks also to carbonite.
Uh,
go to carbonite.com.
Use the offer code,
J r.
E,
n get a free trial,
no credit card required,
plus two free month,
two free bonus months
with your subscription.
That's carbonite.com offer code,
J,
R,
e,
n of course,
always on at.com that's o,
n,
n.
I.
T.
Use a code name Brogan and save
yourself 10% off any an all supplements.
We'll see you guys next week.
Lots of great stuff ahead and,
uh,
that's it for now.
Bye Bye.
Big Kiss as soon as you want.